[Music]
n
nothing is faster and more exhilarating
in chest than a bullet game it's all
about quick thinking and taking
advantage of every opportunity when it
comes blink and you'll miss it how did
he do that despite his popularity bullet
chess only has one annual championship
tournament and now entering its fifth
year the bullet Chess Championship is
stronger than ever three-time Champion
Hikaru Nakamura again looks to defend
his title and add to his impressive
trophy case a brutal finish Nakamura
officially has won the only player who
has ever stopped Nakamura in this event
ALS o returns to take another shot at it
2021 Champion Ali Reza fua that's it
competing with these champions for the
first time in the format the best
all-around player in the world Magnus
Carlson has dominated chess seemingly
forever but he's never played in the
bullet Chess Championship will one of
these big three of bullet take home the
$20,000 crown or can someone else claim
the title maybe nitzki Tang Hansen
kowana it's me that is the Fabiano
finale in this speediest of speed chess
championships only one Champion will
emerge welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
[Music]
Championship welcome everybody the
championship Friday here at the bullet
chest Championship I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me hey what's up
Danny
wrench thanks for having me I've been a
fan I've been watching all week and I'm
super excited to be here it's the final
day I can't wait to see what happens
it's Friday are you are you not gonna
hold anything back I just want to be
clear I'm not gonna hold anything back
last game of the year Dan nothing to
hold back now it's Friday Friday got to
play bullet on Friday whatever you want
today we're going to bring it and the
chess I don't think we could ask for a
better end here with maybe the four best
bullet guest players in the world
throwing down oh we have exciting chess
for you all today it is the BCC and
there are only four players left
standing we started with 16 that has
been whittel down to the four names you
see on the screen in front of you Daniel
nitki took down olander bortnik Magnus
Carlson had his way with Andrew tang and
up at the top it seems like his name is
always etched in the Grand Final it's
AAR Nakamura who beat Ali Rea fuia 16
and half 12 and a half that sent fuja
down to the losers final where he awaits
the winner of the upcoming match between
Daniel nitzki and Magnus Carlson so
Danny we start the day with the profit
the Sensei what are your expectations
for this Fifth and final day of the
BCC well da against Magnus right
obviously that's going to be where the
focus is because that's where we start
winner plays oi Resa I think a lot of
people look at that and think Magnus
Carlson world champion but da da can be
a a streaking creature when he's
confident when he's rolling he can be a
for and uh I wouldn't be surprised that
if da gets off to a hot start that he
might be capable of moving on and
playing all the reses so I'm pumped I'm
pumped to see that obviously a Magnus
Ali Resa losers final to see who gets
AAR in the Grand Final would probably be
um epic as well so anyway I'm I'm ready
I'm ready for all of it and I think what
I said is true not to take anything away
from all the other players I think these
are the four best bullet players on the
planet and so we have what we want here
on Friday oh I won't disagree with that
statement these four have been the best
that's for sure and I also concur with
you that if da is in the form that we've
seen over the last few days and Magnus
he has been shaky like he was against
mlay he needs to improve on that as Ali
Raz said he needs to level up but no
matter who gets through that matchup
they'll still need to play fuja and then
the winner of that in the losers final
goes up to play the Grand Final against
Hikaru Nakamura so what I'm saying is
all roads lead to
Hikaru Queen oh 97 97 he misses the fork
he's good man he's good good he could
take on D5 with check and the problem is
now he has no Ming attack he's got to
turn the game around he's just giving up
his bishop and he's given up what's
going on
here captured and he's getting M FES
he's thinking about winning when he's
losing and then he's going to demoralize
you when he does that Andrew quickly
winning a couple games in a row that is
really important for him oh my gosh he
allowed a Checkmate as soon as I said
winning a couple games
he gets it done again just reminds us
Robert why he's on top of the bullet
world he is your three-time bullet chest
Champion he's also been on a rampage in
this year's Edition you see big wins
over ohanyan Martinez and nitzki fua
that was a hotly contested match it was
close until the very end but Danny 73-
32 overall that's the score in favor of
Nakamura
the margin of Victory there is insane I
know there's all kinds of saber metrics
Advanced analytics uh about uh in other
sports and we continue to to have those
types of historical references as as
this event is now in its fifth year and
I think as we're looking back at this
event in 20 years Robert there will be
conversations like will anybody ever
have a margin of Victory as dominant as
hikara Nakamura you will have
conversations about whether anyone can
touch that type of performance because
73 and 32 is just insane against this
field this isn't like he's farming you
know a 2400 you know what I mean but not
playing me here right he's playing the
best bullet players on the planet and
just dominating it's it's insane it's
been incredible to watch when Hikaru is
in Peak form it feels like he's
Unstoppable but two players who would
like their chance to face off against
iaru and maybe not just once but twice
if they can get all the way to the Grand
Final win are Daniel nitki and Magnus
Carlson and they're awfully impressive
themselves you see DA has played
3,591 games Magnus over 1,000 bullet
games himself the average accuracy well
in magnus's favor but the peak rating in
da so what of these numbers which of
them stand out to you
Danny we could probably talk about this
image honestly Robert for like a half an
hour I mean honestly it's 30,000 Games
first of all is insane but let's
remember that includes hyper bullet as
well we know that da loves himself some
late night hyper bullet if you check out
his streams but also look at the wins by
flag 28% wins by Flag by which proves
that as impressive as that accuracy is
by the world champion who plays 80%
accur 86% accuracy chess in bullet
Magnus Carlson does but it shows that
winning games getting the dub is what
matters in bullet right and you don't
have to play accurate chess when you're
tricking your opponent with awkward
blunders in a Time scramble that make
them flag so da da knows how to get the
job done and um I think that that's a
really important stat right there that
28% wins by flag yeah da promoted to a
knight earlier in the competition just
to not just confuse his opponent but to
make them spend more time as you were
saying and you're completely correct
that it's not about being the most
accurate you need to be lightning fast
and Magnus has been very strong out of
the gates he actually had a huge lead
when he was playing against fuja but
against da I mean down the stretch of
those games it's going to be difficult
the mouse speed is there for D but look
at the new setting behind Magnus he's
back home he was in Barcelona with the
chess bras that should help his
cause yeah we'll see how comfortable he
is now that he's in the in the setup
that we've we've come to know and love
with multiple chairs behind him as I was
just in Oslo I feel like every day was a
constant commentary on the chair setup
um I think there's a couple of secret
lab chairs there hiding so yeah Magnus
now back home looks to be ready and uh I
think as as we said though Robert I
think because of DA's style and how well
he can play when he gets rolling if he's
confident and because we know how good
Magnus Carlson is an early start an
early an early good result for ma for da
is really critical here yeah you cannot
let Magnus get out to a three-game lead
if Magnus wins the first three games
that puts Don in trouble especially
because we have 30 minutes of this match
so you can't go down early against
Magnus but what Dan has done well Danny
is against hikaro in the second game of
their match he was completely lost
blunder a piece he played it out and
actually held a draw in a Time
scramble yeah well and he's going to
need to do more of that right and show
why he wins a lot of games by flagging
we saw saw the stats earlier was 28% for
those of you just tuning in a lot of
games to win by flag flagging but that
means he also draws a lot of games in
time scrambled right he's not an easy
person to put away and so DA has to be
ready for the fight has to be uh has to
not be intimidated by the fact that he's
playing um maybe maybe the greatest
player of all time right and I think if
he keeps himself focused and and does
what he does DA has a very good chance
to move on and face Aldi Resa and the
nerves can't get to either player right
now because even Andrew Tang who's
usually the most Zen of all players play
said he was nervous when he's on his
last life in this double elimination
format so there is a lot at stake right
now because you get the chance to play
against fuja that's all good and fun but
you're guaranteed minimum 12K if you win
this match the loser on the other hand
eliminated into fourth place gets
$88,000 not a bad chunk of change for
the player who does end their tournament
run here but you want that extra $4,000
you want that chance against fuia and
ultimately you want to go play against
aaro and beat him in the Grand Final
yeah everyone wants a chance at the King
right you want a chance at hikaro
Nakamura of course he did win uh he
hasn't won every bullet shest
Championship we all remember the year
that Aldi Resa managed to get the job
done and take him down but overall the
margin of Victory speaks for itself when
it comes to Hikaru um everyone as we as
we showed earlier all roads lead to
Hikaru so everyone wants that chance but
yeah not a bad chunk of change 100 grand
total in prizes for the bullet chest
championship and uh these guys are ready
we uh we've got got a Magnus Carlson
singing on camera that you're all going
to see here in just a second so you know
Magnus is ready when he's like bobing
probably some Taylor Swift can we be
honest that Magnus I bet he finds his
group with a little T Swift on a Friday
afternoon in Norway hey you know
whatever gets him going I think that
deserves to be the music in his ears but
da he looks focused and I know he has
been so da of course good friend as the
game start but he has really been
dedicated to this event going to sleep
earlier Danny you should be proud oh my
gosh don't if that's all I needed to do
to get da to go to bed earlier we should
hold a bullet event every
week Jokes Aside anyone who follows
chess commentary knows that da DA's done
you know he's had his late nights
knowing he needed to wake up at the at
600 am the next day for commentary so um
but we love him and he's been getting
his rest look at him he looks like he
showered he's fresh now he's leaned in
and uh forgets that he's he's a
commentator and now he's just a player
doesn't care how he looks on camera
right now yeah and he shouldn't I mean
he should care about how his position
looks because I see holes in White's
position and Magnus H his KN to C4 all
these light squares under magnus's
control and the clock a 5-second lead
currently for Magnus I think he's got
great chance to take game one with black
yeah and this move A5 is is super nice
obviously already focused on opening the
a file prying down the A3 Pawn I know
it's bullet but positional chest still
matters oh my gosh an E3 crumbling the
king behind it da is uh feeling the hurt
here in the first game yeah Bishop takes
D4 black is going up and minimum in
exchange is a good effort there look
there Queen D4 please take my queen oh
no my queen you take there there was a
back rank mate on
E8 nice little trap oh no my queen and
uh uh da is going to try for every trick
in the book in the books even when he's
down against Magnus today so oh plenty
more where that came from wow so Magnus
allowed Rook D7 because he had spotted
Rook A1 check now Magnus up a full Rook
into this end game and has plenty of
time to convert the to
win yeah time is critical here any game
we're evaluating a Magnus Carlson
Advantage you have to look at the clock
before you uh chalk it up to the books
right there Magnus Carlson does take the
first game with black and he's ready
he's back home feeling a little more
comfy maybe and uh here we
go and this looks like a kacan to me but
it started with D4 Knight F6 so it's it
was a jabaa London turned into a sort of
kacan turned into whatever this is and I
feel like da he is going to be down on
the clock in the early stages of the
game Magnus is the better prepared
player between the two something Hikaru
said that da has been changing his
openings against Naka and maybe against
some of the other top players and that
could actually be detrimental rather
than helpful because you spend time but
actually look at this tactic from that
trap the F2 pal Agnes missed that that's
a super nice trick the F2 Palm was
hanging I think that's a great point
though overall when you're not playing
positions that you're comfortable with
where the plans are almost subconscious
it can really hurt you in bullet when
you really need to play quickly on the
clock so if DA has to change his
openings against top players not a great
sign oh and look at that he blundered
his Knight oh man he had such a good
position that super unfortunate that
move Rook D1 by Magnus took away a
checking square and now da resigns
because he's losing his Rook on D7 to
follow so that must be frustrating you
steal a pawn with a nice tactic and then
a few moves later you blunder a piece in
the
center we talk about that a lot I know
it's hard to get instructive moments and
bullet but you can't take for granted
that a tactic may not work the move
before Robert your opponent does
something that makes it work and you are
you were borderline pre-moving and so
you blundered Magnus really heads up
play there to take away that Queen D4
check and actually renew the threat of
F3 and he wins the game yeah and now we
get into this third game here in Magnus
with the black pieces trying to stop
checkman he does but his Pawn structure
is shattered great position I would say
for da he's also keeping steady in the
clock but now Magnus will he show that
endgame technique that's made him the
highest rated player in
history and you called it though out of
the gates I I said da needs to make sure
he doesn't fall behind you specifically
said that a 3 deficit would be really
really problematic and right now Don is
staring down the barrel of that gun and
look at that though he's rising to the
occasion he's one upon now two he's got
three passers good stuff here from da to
make sure he doesn't fall behind three
games do you see that smile da smiled
and took a drink right that was actually
very
adorable can we clip and ship that
please that's what that's the feeling
you know the feeling of beating a world
champion that video we did of artv
that's the feeling of beating a world
champion in bullet right there big smile
from da nitki yeah i' love to see that
Magnus does not like to see that because
you do not want to give da that kind of
confidence when DA's in that flow state
where he's just moving his intuition is
superb and so Magnus knows that he
respects that and here with the white
pieces Magnus is taking all the space in
the position but when you push pawns
forward you leave them vulnerable in the
future so watch out for this E4 Pawn in
particular and also this B4 Pawn
yeah the B4 Pawn is look at that da
finds a trick because if you took you
would have lost the Knight on F3 due to
and look at that now he wins The
Exchange da rolling if he evens up this
match that's the confident da we called
that would be capable of winning today
he's got to get out to a good start
early and I love how he's playing but
did you see that by Magnus trading
Queens when down material because if the
Rook slides up then you lose the Rook to
the other Bishop that was actually sick
from Magnus the ability to spot all that
in the blink of an eye but but look at
da right back at it with a trick himself
with that G5 move that saved the
exchange that was nasty I I don't know
that he's going to win but look he might
be on on Route is there a mating net
here there has to be where is it I was
thinking Rook takes F6 but I don't think
that worked just yet but uh oh yeah oh
oh he might have wondered at the oh
Bishop Bishop F3 and then Rook G6 and
then Bishop back oh my gosh what is
happening here this looks very close I
have no
idea E6 the pawn pushes and then is
there H5 Jack oh my gosh and it's
falling apart wait Rook G6 Rook
G6 see it coming oh Rook takes F oh he
took the wrong piece and he why did he
take G5 he's get M it back
here oh my God Rook takes F6 was good
not Rook G5 oh and Don just making a few
moves resigns and look at the smile on
his face he's like I cannot believe that
I just out calculated Magnus Carlson and
then still made a mistake and
lost that is what the bullet chest
Championship is made of right there
games like that of course we see the uh
the real time engine analysis showing
there were obviously a number of
blunders and Miss WIS there but it
doesn't matter it's entertaining chess
and da misses his opportunity to level
the
score okay but he goes right back into
the game and he's playing quickly and
he's got a french-like structure and
it's the best French I've ever seen
black doesn't have a LightCore Bishop
the pawn structure is shattered on the
queen side for white but black castles
into the pressure Danny we usually say
the side with a safer King is usually
the side with the advantage and bullet I
don't think black's King is particularly
safe black king is not safe da is
uh very easy plans here I think to play
on the queen side the knight's popping
into D6 just as you highlight look at
that move d4 this is an easy position
for white to play which is key in bullet
swing The Rook back over yep he does it
I like where Don's going here got to
keep this thing close very instructive
from da his Rook was on B1 pressuring
the the black king and he just says let
me go over to the king side and uhoh he
did just drop two Pawns in a row one of
them with check the H Pawn may be
dangerous
Danny yeah the H Pawn is super dangerous
the king is also in an awkward spot
there here oh he was threatening Rook G6
and Rook
H6 crazy that the engine can say this is
an equal position that's so unfair to
chess it is but look at the cluck as you
said who cares what your accuracy is
look at the time I think that da should
try to flag Magnus here
100% agreed that you can't let games
like this go by you got to flag him
especially when there's a knight on the
board right so many tricks possible like
Forks in fact that's a huge heads up
play by Magnus to get the knights off
the board dirty flag him it's Rook
against rook and pawn who cares do not
repeat moves give checks and if you're
Magnus you probably just do not push the
pawn that way you get a 50 move rule yep
yep yeah at this point the writing is on
the wall that you're not going to have
enough time to win if you're Magnus so
don't push the pawn and take the draw no
draw this isn't surg for Bobby fer
that's a win for Daniel
nitzki he raises his hand apologetically
da is such a sweetheart for those who
don't know the level of respect DA has
for just the the sanctity of the game of
chess as someone who Flags people a lot
28% of his victories you should just
know da feels bad about every single
dirty flag he's ever done genuinely mhm
that was that was like in tennis when
you hit a really hard shot and then hits
the net and then gently rolls over
you're like sorry about that like you
got the point the way you needed to
there was nothing unethical about it so
da he is only down by one point his
position looks really bad from the black
side and by the way we saw that chat
voted and 22% of You Believe In Da the
70 other 78% think Magnus is going to
win yeah I I don't think that's a huge
surprise Magnus wins a lot of votes uh
when people ask who's going to win a
match look at this there's a trick here
on the
board wh's D7 Pawn I guess is is going
to rule the day here in the end that's
the problem mhm D7 and Pa will push
don't look at that by Magnus do not take
the bishop cu the king would have rushed
over to E7 to win the pawn so Bishop E3
a stellar Retreat and here comes the
bishop to C7 and that should be
it yeah nice heads up defense though
getting the oh but Magnus he'll have
none of it you will not slow down the
pawn a little head Bob that t Swift you
know hitting it hitting it let's just
hope it's not Carly Ray jeffson whoa
nothing wrong with Carly Ray yeah what
are you gonna I just what what just
happened there why you I said that why
going Carly Ray Json why don't we talk
about Shawn M for a second whoa 96 that
P was pinned do that whoa 96 check he
blundered it and Don Don Just Smiles but
Magnus laughing a little bit oh wait
it's not over thought it was just over
winning this is very complicated game
where Black's up in exchange and look at
that awareness from Magnus Queen H5 gets
those Queens off the board black isn't
even better but black does have two
Rooks to wh's
one yeah this has completely turned
around for a game that started with a
knight D6 check borderline smothered
mate Magnus gets the Queens off the
board heads up play which makes his King
safe and now he should be winning in
this end game but I'm looking at the
clocks and anytime I see Magnus within a
couple seconds of Da I'm actually
worried for Magnus because da is faster
in these time scrambles there's plenty
of time left too much extra material for
black for the moment but Don is smart to
play this out
totally agreed especially if you're not
down you know at this point there's
still 19 minutes left in the match
you're not in a position where you need
a new game to get a oh and he he finds a
fork just like that it's turning back
around second Knight D6 of the game and
that's going in DA's way still up upon
is Magnus Carlson and he's up a couple
seconds but I'm telling you Magnus would
want to be up four seconds into time
scrambles because Don is
faster yep you could already sort of
smell the dirty flag coming here you can
like you can smell it and and Magnus can
feel it too look at the level of
pre-moving that he's engaged
here hoping for a draw oh no draw Magnus
played on actually wants more Magnus is
slightly ahead on the clock but Don's
King gets back in time it's in the box
so the black king will eat D3 be draw
anyway okay Danny but Don was lost
objectively and he fought back because
he knows when to resign and when to play
on
and I was actually surprised by magnus's
decision to keep pushing there I think
that if he does that too many
times he might regret it because
especially when you have a two- game
lead I would be okay with the draw
rather than take my chances in a dirty
flag competition with da I don't want to
be in a dirty flag competition with that
guy right and so I'm a little I'm a
little surprised by that risk that risk
there that Magnus took yeah because
yesterday hikaro against Ali Raza Hikari
won bishop and Rook Pawn a draw because
it was the wrong color Bishop for the
corner a couple time he just flagged Ali
Raza the same exact end game we almost
saw for the second time this match Rook
against rook and a couple pawns to a win
in time trouble right now we're seeing
da try to use the queenside to his
Advantage he's down in exchange not the
first time today we've seen that but
he's gobbling up queenside pawns and
that's a passer
yep yeah this is I mean objectively a
very balanced position in bullet it's
actually hard to choose which side is
easier to play the Bishops in the pass
Pawn feel good but long-term that Knight
will be tricky in the time scramble but
look at that move Bishop A2 he's say
your your rook's useless and Bishop H6
Bishop C1 how is white going to defend
this you have to go Knight A3 at the end
of it oh Magnus
Magnus I don't know what he anticipated
there unclear but da is in charge and
look at the clock by the way not only is
Da probably better with the two Bishops
versus The Rook he is well ahead on time
and as long as he doesn't blunder a
piece he should be able to take this
game agreed
yeah this is uh DA's game to win look at
the time Advantage just increasing for
nitki
here this is the position Magnus is
afraid of doesn't want to be in these
spots DA's gonna I think bring this
thing within a game here and if I'm Da I
don't know how many moves have been made
but I might throw in G4 at the moment
trying to catch oh gave up a pawn so
losing a pawn is actually a good thing
because there's no 50 move rolling oh
but that's not good oh that's not a good
thing but Magnus only has two seconds
not going to oh he's going to get
everything off the board oh he had a
chance take the bishop he had a chance
oh
wow wow what a save by Magnus there and
that is unfortunate for da because that
was a rare chance to get a victory he
didn't take it yeah that was a save by
Magnus so he's proving you guys may call
me out and say I can't handle myself in
the scrambles he said NOP this one I
have under control but honestly that was
Da blundering a piece he was trying to
pre-move uh the way through and now with
the white pieces though look at this for
da apparently it's just winning for
white Don's DA's keeping with it here
and you know not only is he better in
these well he's consistently up on time
Magnus did just hold his own in that
scramble but DA's been playing a high
level of Chess here Bishop A6 what a
tricky move he blundered look at this
The Rook is under attack4 there's F5
yeah and if you defend the Rook then you
lose the knight at the end so I think
what is how's this equal
is it some sort of check and queen H4
guarding the Rook no at the end there's
you know what it is Danny it's Rook
takes A8 and Knight D7 Knight f8 and
then the king can't escape oh my god
with a Perpetual but that that's
impossible to
find I don't think Magnus sees it and I
definitely think da doesn't see it
because he's clearly frustrated he
actually just resigned oh my gosh that's
one of those where the engine is just so
unfair for us but it is actually a
really cool thing cuz the instructive
moment of this this Perpetual on night
of eight we never would have spotted no
if not for the computer saying the
position was level I mean we sat there
clueless for a little bit and how was
this equal and like okay you're telling
me it's equal any queen move seem to
lose a piece so let's go for that and
that is ridiculous you can't expect to
find that even in a Blitz game and
bullet no shots so da with the black
pieces he just stole a pawn he's
actually playing quite well in this
match
read yeah here he goes he's up a
pawn and uh up on the clock
significantly by the way yeah this is an
opportunity to stay with it get it back
within a couple games after that that
crazy
loss but Magnus is also you know he's
playing he's pulling a da too even when
he's losing he's making it hard he's
dragging it out and if he does have a
lead it's in his it's in his best
interest to get as much time off the
clock as possible only 13 minutes remain
right now oh we have a blunder that
gonna get it with the fist pump let's go
that was a nice game from start to
finish as da secures his fourth point in
the match is now 6 to four and we have
to remember that it's win by two so as
long as da can cut this to a one-point
deficit even if time elapses he's still
in
this
yeah all right what do we got now we've
got a a simple boring looking
symmetrical position but da on the prowl
I like the way you described it you know
yeah they just trade off all the pieces
only e file is open this looks like it
should be drawish but I'm looking at the
clock I think da perfectly happy with
equal positions where there are pieces
left on the board and he can try to
outplay magn although with that move is
he saying I'm okay with the
draw yeah I wonder
it's probably true that he's okay with a
draw on this one but I don't know that
Magnus will take that we know that
Magnus is super tricky we saw him okay
he does take a draw gonna say we saw him
win two night end games against his
buddy Jordan Von fuest at the Champions
chess tour last week of of course a
little bit of a different format in in a
rapid setting than a bullet setting but
uh but okay and I wonder if da if he
really needs to win that game let's say
there was the last game of the match I
he would have played that out and maybe
he could have posed some problems
because he is that fast and credit to
Magnus because Magnus he's improved his
game I think the Magnus we're seeing Now
is better than we've seen in the last
few days he is leveling up as said he
had
to yeah I agreed he's playing uh playing
better again more focused maybe a little
more comfy in his home setting than he
was on the road whether it's enough to
get by da Ali Reza and hikaro Nakamura
okay that's uh that's going to be quite
the tale if Magnus can complete a
comeback and ultimately win today but
we'll we'll deal with that later right
now we've got a rook end game with
Queens on the board da again holding his
own but Magnus up on the clock here yeah
he is up a few seconds he gets his Queen
in oh but speaking of Queen in that
could be scary for the king and Magnus
he offers a queen sh A3 B6 both under
attack because of the The Rook placement
for white so whoa is D going for more
with that B5
move I think he is and I think he should
the past a pun you know whether
objectively Black's better or not poses
some problems practically for white look
at this he wants to break up he loses
the past Aon right as I say it and
Magnus has turned it around da on the
defensive oh can't take wait you can't
take R
yeah that's a problem so that means yeah
mag have too much time Danny yeah he's
goingon to play Rook B8 and then sack
the queen on C7 oh but watch out for the
draw oh oh oh what yeah why did it go
very far down there not sure a second
Queen but there's a mate threat on G2
okay not anymore yeah it was it was
there forl we've seen games already
where someone's Queen didn't help them
stop mate earlier in the bullet chest
championship this week so not to be not
to be there for da Magnus increases his
lead I mean really nicely done there by
Magnus converting that Advantage he
stole the A3 pawn and never looked back
and here da is playing one of his pet
lines it's this jabala London system
where look at these Knights these
Knights are on dark squares that's a
bishop on a light Square I'll put the
knights in green but they're outclassing
that light Square Bishop which is
staring to thin
air yeah
so pretty Knight's on dark squares oh
Queen C8 Queen C8 apparently not great
hey that
rhymed now we're rolling what is going
on here look at this mag the attack da
let's go Magnus sacked his rook and then
it sacked a pawn in the center this is
getting very confusing but it looks like
Magnus has gone
astray it looks like he's gone astray
but I don't I don't with every move the
evaluation seems to change and then
there was potential Knight F2 so the
Queens come off the
board from a practical perspective I
don't know who is easier to play though
in bullet here that D- Pawn is so
dangerous and you have to sacrifice for
it so he's going to give a check oh he's
making the draw that he could have had
in the other game but I wonder but is
there a Ming net is there ah there's no
nothing more than a draw yeah this Pawn
too
strong ah and da he spent a bit of time
there calculating but he needs all the
time that making sure but he needs the
time that's the thing you want to win
it's tough yeah no I I don't disagree
that you got to make those decisions as
fast as you can but I think D you just
wanted to make sure he wasn't missing
right right we have the luxury of the
eal bar saying it's a draw he didn't
want to walk away from from a mating
net um all right vov structure with
G3 Magnus knows these positions well and
now this move G4
wow and O this Queen lands in the center
but Rook hits it and is there an attack
this G4 Pawn is loose over here but
maybe there's a problem if you take it
the G file opens up against the black
king and trying to see it does take it
that's a brave decision from da and he's
in sort of that must-win territory so
why not go for it and we might see
another repetition clever stuff here
from
Magnus
and from Magnus to save the draw we're
now sorry what I say Magnus is not
moving because he has the draw by
repetition this is where gamesmanship
comes in he's only going to make that
draw when he's down to like two seconds
left we see d uh sorry we see Magnus
chuckling all the players know that
there's that kind of larger meta
strategy in these SEC formats whether
it's the bullet just Championship or the
championship you have to use the clock
but it kind of makes them laugh CU
that's such an element that has never
existed in chess right before this
format where you're basically playing
another game that isn't on the board and
uh you got to respect it because what
he's doing there Robert is saying that
he respects DA's ability to make a
comeback right so don't take it the
wrong way he's like look I'm milking the
format here because I know what bullet
is I know what da is capable of and I'm
gonna get every second off the clock
that I can yeah it's a smart strategy
we've seen hikaro do that over the years
and I saw a feature chat saying the
Hikaru way the best players who have
been around who have played these
formats they know what to do and oh
Magnus castles Queen side and we're
going to see it Alpha zero style open up
this H file Y and go for an attack Here
Comes Harry Simon Williams not with us
today but always here in spirit Harry
for the win and uh that's going to be
very dangerous for da and D has to just
drum up some queenside pressure if he
can but oh no Danny the pawns are
dropping in front of the white king
feels too
dangerous this is looking this is
looking painful and a victory here would
stretch the lead to four games with
probably roughly six and a half minutes
left this is uh H getting hard it's win
or go home and it needs to start right
about now if you're da because Magnus is
almost in the territory where he can
just start letting the clock pick yeah
let's see with 6 minutes and 30 seconds
remaining and Don needing to score three
wins in a row to cut it to one so there
is enough time barely but D needs to win
the next three
games uhoh uhoh got to start now off to
a oh yeah he's pre-moving everything
position here he blundered a pawn
because he's like pre-moving
non-stop oh
H it's good strategy you know you might
lose this game but a draw a loss is the
same for the match so you need to move
instantly win instantly and D is doing
all he
can
yeah four games is the deficit you don't
want it to become five so but you're in
that weird spot Robert where If you
defend this position for a minute for a
minute longer and hold a draw that hurts
too because you just lost another mid in
on the clock and didn't get a victory so
da needs to find a way to Swindle this
night end game and get a tricky a tricky
win uh I think he swindled himself there
by pushing the pawn and leaving A6
behind oh and Magnus he might not even
want to win he's going for the win but I
thought he just might make the draw
there yeah Knight D3 Knight C5 was a
draw there but he wants more
a win here essentially puts the match
away right we never want to call it too
soon but it's getting tough it's going
to be under five minutes with a five
game
deficit oh man this was awesome though
is it weird that I'm already excited for
next year's bullet chest Championship
we're right here I'm already like you
know why I'm excited for that Danny and
this is not a shout out in a bad way
it's a shout in a good way nihal sain
wherever you are right now I know you're
probably going to watch this at some
point please play you invited I know
you're busy but we would love to see
nihal join the party because we have the
best bullet players on the planet here
and I feel like nihal is really the name
that is absent from this
field I completely agree um it'll also
help with the uh the Twitter hate that I
received from all of your fans in India
ni house sain because they thought we
didn't invite you of course we invited
you and so next year you have to play to
that so that people know we didn't mess
that up and well this match it's in the
books by right now A five-point margin
and we'll see how it ends but you can
see Magnus bopping his head he's a
different Magnus than we saw earlier in
the competition he is back home that
probably helps he's on his normal setup
but he's also just playing a lot better
and I would say faster in the scrambles
when he was uh playing from Barcelona
Danny I don't know if you watched this
part he was like shaking his hand after
every game he said his hand was falling
to sleep he didn't have a good setup so
at home Magnus seems to be increasingly
dangerous for the
opposition it sounds silly but this
format as much as anything brings out
the sporting elements of the physical
setup players have at home right you
need a table that supports your wrist I
mean seriously right if you're on an
awkward table and your wrist is on the
edge everyone has had that right you
can't play with a touch pad unless
you're Robert Hess you know I mean
seriously you need your setup to do well
and and the physical elements of
whatever whatever makes chess and esport
if you want to call it that are really
highlighted in this event and uh and
we'll see if that is enough to help
Magnus turn around his fortunes and and
maybe maybe make it all the way to the
Grand Final and I'm not going to lie we
can already start talking about it I
still see Ali Resa as the favorite in
the next round I love da we're not
looking past him but this one's over and
I think that fuja Magnus is uh we're
about to break the internet here and I
think ol resa is still the slight
favorite against the former World Champ
not sure if you agree he did beat Magnus
a couple days ago and he started with a
3oh lead and the final margin was a
three-point match victory for Ali Rea so
I think that Ali rea proven himself to
be the best Contender to uh hikaro
nakamura's title in fact alza won the
2021 edition of this event by beating
Hikaru and wow as we look at this
position Magnus well on his way to
another Victory it would seem with a
huge attack and a huge lead on the clock
I I think that you're right that aliv is
the favorite but Magnus in this form the
way he just demonstrated his bullet
skills against da here I think that he's
showing that he should not be overlooked
himself I agree I agree well we're going
to see what happens here in probably
about 15 minutes in total fans go call
everybody be like hey what are you doing
why are you working it's Friday come
watch the bullet chest Championship
because the bleep is about to go down it
is Friday people you know they might
take it easy and the real question is
are you sitting in the front seat or
sitting in the back seat right I either
way I'm having a party party and party
with you party and yeah I don't remember
exactly the line but hey here we go oh
what's 97 what happened there Magnus
going with the
fork going with the fork Fork Town E7
Town C5 hangst Town Don gonna get a win
Town yeah no D he has played a really
good match so even though the the margin
of Victory right now is quite heavily in
magnus's favor part of that was induced
by the lack of time where D started he
he played not even bullet chest he play
hyper bullet in a one minute game uh but
Magnus is the deserved winner but I
think what I'm trying to say is that da
has proven himself to be a seriously
awesome player and we knew that but it's
also good to see him against Hikaru
against Magnus and they're going to be
the only two people who have beaten him
yeah well I mean especially because joh
is a guy you watch play bullets so much
right everyone is a fan of of of Da nisy
stream and and I think sometimes the
haters if you want to call them that
would be like ah but how does da do
against the best guys in the world and
we see he holds his own he beats these
guys and and frankly I think there were
a couple games earlier in this match
that if they had gone the other way
because bullet is such a game of
momentum who knows right and again the
final score is what it is for a reason
Magnus Carlson is going to win by
probably roughly six six games here even
if da gets this one but but I I think
DA's chess has been better than the
final result so that's my long-winded
way of saying I agree with you Robert
and I love you I I I appreciate both
those
things um and we are going to get one
more game so 15 seconds on the match
clock and D is Happ but he as you were
saying earlier he has so much respect
for the game of chess but he has this
loyalty to the game so much that he
respects the top players maybe too much
at times I think that he respect the
like he doesn't want to flag them he he
put up his hands but you have to be
Shameless in the bullet Chess
Championship there are no friends as we
found out yesterday when he played his
good friend Alexander bortnik but da he
gets one more game he relishes the
opportunity to play against the best of
the best and right now all right in this
final one he is worse but let's see if
he can pull out another Victory one for
the road
yep Two for the Money one for the road
three to get ready and four to go one
wait that I said it wrong but you get it
yeah I know what you're trying to
do and uh he okay the Bishops are are
nasty but Knights are tricky in a Time
scramble so if he can keep it close
Magnus by the way is just like feeling
it right we saw him DJing the other
night or something now we see him just
bobbing his head and
uh he's in his own I think there's
something therapeutic when when you're
in the flow as you I think that's what
you said earlier when you're in the flow
listening to music playing a game you
love I think the players really really
love this format yeah and I think Magnus
loves the fact that he's moving on he
gets another chance against ala and we
know that Vengeance it motivates some
people and Magnus not really an
exception to that he says winning once
that's not revenge and he would like to
take down Al and imagine da going for a
little
[Music]
cheeky please take my funny that was so
funny oh you can't the look at that look
at
the and
laugh to a knight does does Magnus have
Auto Queen on take it it and get a
knight take it yeah hold alt and promote
you a knight we're going to definitely
make sure Magnus knows
that that was that was good by the way
fans for the inside joke in case you're
not realizing it's stalemate if you take
the Rook that's what's going on here and
Magnus mag just plays along oh that was
so good so good I don't think Magnus
knows how to that he is doesn't have to
Auto Queen if he holds down alt and
Hammer has experienced that his
compatriot and his friend so da he gets
a draw that was hilarious a great way to
end that match yep that was awesome
couple of Thumbs Up da acknowledging
whatever our team is telling in behind
the scene producers fair play I think
you might be joining us for an interview
and uh that was awesome what a fun way
to end it da held his own against uh as
our as our show open says the greatest
all-around player of all time will he
win the bullet just Championship when
today is done we we don't know yet but
Magnus does win this match 12 and a half
7 and a half yeah five-point match
victory for Magnus Carlson and for da
you he was smiling at the end he
deserves to hold his head up high he put
forth a great fight to Magnus and this
is a different Magnus than in previous
days that's clear to me so Magnus he
deserves the Lion's Share of the praise
here beating Daniel nitzki by five in a
30-minute bullet match but da I mean
there's nothing to be disappointed about
there it was a really good tournament
for him he beat Andrew Tang by eight
points he beat bortnik he's done very
very well throughout this event he just
got stopped by first taru and second
Magnus yeah it's not a bad it's not a
bad story to tell right I lost to hikaro
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson you'll take
that one along with the eight grand that
you get for playing uh in the fourth
place final position so uh amazing stuff
again I think we called it we knew that
da needed to get off to a good start if
if he had managed a little better there
who knows what happens bullet is such a
game of momentum even more than any
other format we have online and Magnus
gets it rolling and couldn't be stopped
and the bracket now is down to three
remaining players as Daniel nitzki exits
the field it is Ali Raza fua against
Magnus Carlson there in the losers final
and the winner of this match they will
their name will be placed right
underneath Hikaru Nakamura in the Grand
Final so there is a lot at stake in the
match that is coming up but before we
get there we're going to get an
interview with Daniel n
so the chat please you know get involved
you ask your questions we'll feature
some of them and I'm just really excited
to hear D's thoughts on the flip side of
this
break this course is about white playing
D4 all the tools you need to get in
Advantage with Wy and not be tricked
early in the
opening now it has a really long
complicated name that I'm going to
mispronounce now so you can make fun of
me he don't make fun of me too much I'm
I'm trying to help you here it's called
the chalins variation and I'm probably
mispronouncing cellin that's why I call
it the A6
[Music]
SLO
and then there were three we are now
down to the final Trio of participants
here in the bullet Chess Championship
Magnus Carlson he moved on after
defeating Daniel nitzki it was a fun
match it was you know tight for a few
there but Magnus pulled away with
impressive speed
Edy yeah he did and uh he he won on the
board he also held his own on the clock
against uh a guy who as we saw when we
did the head-to-head stats wins 28% of
his bullet game by flagging people da is
the best in the biz when it comes to
dirty flagging but Magnus held his own
ultimately got the job done will'll get
the uh we'll get another chance against
the guy who sent him to the losers
bracket in all the res of peruja and
before we see Magnus get that chance we
are going to bring in none other than
Dan nitki for an interview da sorry that
this match didn't go your way I mean you
impress so many people along the way I
know it must be tough just to be on the
back of an elimination year but are you
glad that you played and how are you
feeling about your overall
level yeah well thank you very much
obviously I'm I'm really really sad to
to be eliminated and not to have a an
outside shot at at the top three um but
I'm more than happy I played it was
really an honor to to participate in the
tournament my my like minimum goal was
to not make a fool of myself maybe beat
a couple of good players and I knew that
realistically if Magnus andaru play in
the best conditions I don't have much of
a chance against them and um they did
and I gave them a really really good
fight I think even this match was pretty
close if a couple of games had gone my
way uh this this could have been you
know a one or two-point match so I'm I'm
really proud of the way that I that I
fought against them you know I'm not
I've got nothing to be embarrassed about
I lost to Magnus and Hikaru and you know
I'm more than happy to take my hat off
these two players are just
otherworldly and I really had the time
of my life so um any any bullet
tournament like this sign me up I'll be
the first in
line Anya you obviously as you said have
nothing to be embarrassed about at all
losing to hiar Nakamura and Magnus
Carlson is is a good thing to write home
about but for so many people you have so
many fans they watch you play they watch
you dominate other people on stream
where you are just worldly you are
otherworldly you are in a class above
the majority of human beings who play
chess especially in bullet so if you if
you don't mind what what is the thing
that separates Magnus Hikaru a little
bit and may if it's not just one thing
but in the experience of playing them
what did you feel allows them to just
pull away in those big
moments I think Magnus and yukar are two
are two different beasts so the the
formula that makes each one of them
great I think is is a little bit
distinct but without delving too deeply
into the into you know the particulars
of of what distinguishes the two um I'll
take Magnus because I spoke about hikaro
a little bit in yesterday's interview in
terms of Magnus um I think it's you know
three or four different things that he
does better than anybody else on the
plan I mean first of all what Magnus
andar both have in common are openings
like I am not a professional player I
don't study openings I don't have a a
seveners team preparing files for me and
when they take matches seriously like
Magnus did today and they play their
main repertoire their understanding of
the positions that that they're most
comfortable with are off the charts like
they will make a move in one second that
I very likely wouldn't be able to come
up with in a classical game um it's also
the consistency Magnus today was able to
avoid one move blunders and the blunders
he did make were mostly like a pawn uh
or maybe an exchange and it's very
important not to not blunder because
that's not possible but to make sure the
blunders you make uh don't immediately
get you to a lost position that was the
difference between our two blunders
right not all blunders are created equal
um so there was that consistency and of
course the speed is is really
unbelievable I'm fast in time scrambles
right like I'm fast
in a rook versus Rook situation but in
the early middle game the speed with
which Magnus makes decisions in critical
moments is crazy like my mouth literally
Falls open and it really is just an
honor to be on the receiving end of that
and to to play in a way that allows
Magnus to bring out that strength so I
was happy that you know that that I
forced him to do that but when when
these two players are in their best form
it's literally like playing an engine
you it's it's almost
indistinguishable oh d i we love to hear
that I mean the admiration respect you
have for them is clear to all and I I
just want to note that you smiled when
you got your first Victory against
Magnus very few people on this planet
can say they've beaten Magnus in any
time control but what does that moment
feel
like well it's it's a it's a moment that
I'm going to you know tell my grandkids
about and I'm going to make clear that I
got crushed by Magnus 99% of the time
that we played but just the feeling of
beating the greatest player who's ever
lived in the history of humankind is
already something that I'm going to hang
my hat on especially because again I
wear many many hats I really I don't
study chests anymore with any kind of
regularity and I think some people kind
of expect me to go toe-to-toe against
Magnus and huk Carl which was a little
bit absurd from my perspective I'm just
happy when I give them a fight and when
you're able to win a game it gives you a
big rush like it just gives you uh a lot
of confidence and particularly in which
I managed to outplay him which there
were only a couple in this match but uh
each one of them is is something that
that I'm going to remember many years
down the line so it it really does mean
mean a lot if if you can get them to to
sweat a little
bit you definitely do make them sweat uh
and you did in this event da I have a
question from featured chat we've got uh
username r1p Jack wants to know if you
could play Magnus again in a few hours
what would you do differently if
anything well I would definitely check
uh one4 a little bit more carefully I
think I struggled throughout this
tournament uh in responding to one E4
like I tried many different openings but
it's like whatever I played Magnus had
the perfect line prepared nidor he was
playing G3 and crushing me alakin he
refrained from the four pawns which I
actually prepared but it's like he had a
six sense and and he played the most
annoying line so I would take the prep a
little bit more seriously and uh other
than that I I'll be totally honest I I'm
very proud of the way that I played I I
did my absolute best I was locked in I
didn't have the feeling that I was
playing badly I had the feeling that I
was playing to the absolute best of my
ability so the short answer is nothing I
just think Magnus is a better chess
player uh across all time controls and
I'm I'm more than happy to admit
that you know it's important to be
honest we always appreciate your honesty
and I'm going to put you on a spot a
little bit here da brex Carl asks who
are you rooting for for to win the
BCC who am I no I can't you know I like
all three of these players equally um
I'm equally deferential to them I'm a
commentator I can't I definitely can't
reveal anything on that front but I just
want a good match honestly uh it would
be great if Rea uh if Reza strikes I I
think one thing that annoyed me a little
bit is how people sometimes in the Chess
World are you very quick to uh make
these Grand pronouncements about
somebody being washed or somebody being
on the decline and I think alza has
shown this tournament that he's still
ala freaking fuja uh so I think it's
going to be a really difficult match for
Magnus he might have to step up his game
even more uh but if he plays the way he
did against me I think we're in for an
absolutely epic fight so I didn't answer
your question as usual Robert but uh I
just want some good matches yeah at
least go answer my text and we're gonna
let you go so do that also you know you
got to get your prep ready for aliv R's
next candidas tournament when you play
Marathon bullet sessions but for now D
it's been an absolute treat thank you so
much for stopping by and congratulations
you really deserve congrats for what was
a fantastic performance at the BCC it's
it's been a great privilege to to play
in this tournament alongside Magnus and
hikaro and obviously you Danny Simon did
a an incredible job commentating and I'm
always ready to be back so thanks to
everybody for supporting me throughout
the event I really couldn't have done it
without the wholesomeness of the chess
Community who are always behind me so
all friends and family you know my mom
was watching
uh really really helped me do very very
well so thank you everybody hi Lena bye
Lena bye
[Laughter]
da well da nitki you know has nothing to
be ashamed of that was a fantastic
performance throughout the bullet chest
championship for him but he is
eliminated from the field we are moving
on to Ali Raza versus Magnus part two
and Danny as we dissect the numbers on
screen here Peak rating in Ali raz's
favor number of games Ali raz's favor
wins by flag and losses by flag about
the same so what's noteworthy to you
here I I was going to highlight not just
the the wins by flag and losses by flag
but the accuracy I mean this is a
borderline coin flip right look at that
there's a reason oi res of fuja uh beat
Magnus Carlson before and uh he wants to
do it again right these two guys are are
are just locked in it's a 50/50 match in
my opinion here the the stats say it we
know that the fans are probably not sure
who's going to take this one I still
think fua if he plays the way that he
did a couple days ago when he sent Magus
to the losers bracket is is the favorite
but I wonder Robert and I want your
opinion on this do you think as the day
goes on Magnus Carlson gets stronger
right almost like uh you know you think
of Dragon Ball Z right he reaches
whatever 9,000 like as the day goes on
the fact that you came from the losers
bracket and are carrying momentum
working out all the Kinks and really
just kind of feeling it might really be
in Magnus Carlson's favor yeah I think
also playing somebody in a series of
games the more games that you play
usually the better it is for Magnus
Carlson because he gets a feel of the
opponent and Magnus I don't think we
could talk about this enough he is back
home now when he played from Barcelona
there were tons of distractions there I
mean he was in the chess bar house they
were having the times of their lives he
wasn't on his typical you mean the chess
BR are
distracting well I think that they are
very entertaining and so Magnus
correctly was like oh they're great
people to talk to and watch and drink
you know cocktails or mocktails with but
I mean in all seriousness we saw the
graphic and with their insights they are
very neck and neck and in that first
match alza won but he won by three games
and he won the first three games of the
match so Magnus if he's more competitive
in the early stages of this match I
think we could see a different
outcome I agree especially because
regardless of of Ali Resa being as da
called him Ali Ali freaking fza right
Ali freaking fua um it despite that
Magnus Carlson still has that edge right
that that that made him the goat and got
him to be the best player in the world
the highest rated player in history that
I think if he gets on a role there's a
little bit of a psych psychological
Factor right where players can struggle
against him because he's Magnus and so
you really called it well I think if if
Magnus gets off to a good start
maybe maybe this match goes the other
way right and he's the one winning by
three gam so I either way at this point
no more speculation needed we have Jess
on the board baruja with a little bit of
an edge here to start game one yeah
although the pawn structure are such
that it looks pretty bad for white I'm
looking the clock Magnus up 15 seconds
so he was doing this in their first
match he was well ahead in the clock but
what Magnus just showed against da he
has the mouse speed at the end of the
game as well so right now I'm liking
mags's position he may be uh you know
actually not even Dow any material
anymore after he stole the D Pawn whoa a
queen sack because if you take the Queen
the B Pawn would become a c pawn and
then become a new
one yeah that was awesome okay it's
still a 50/50 game but as you said
Magnus way up on the clock uhoh but now
things have turned around and perou has
got attack Magnus is like unbelievable
there wait no Magnus Magnus turned it
around there I'm sorry I was losing
track of who was who no you're you're
fine that's happens in bullet even for
the players like am I black in this
position yeah you are oh my goodness
Bishop takes H3 with mate on H2 that's a
win a brilliant move to start game one
with a little bit of a headbob whatever
Tunes he's listening to it is working
for Magnus Carlson yeah that was the
best start you could possibly imagine
and now alliv is with the black pieces
look at this opening Advantage for
Magnus he gives I I think in bullet
chess having double isolate pawns is the
worst thing in the world yeah well I
mean even in Reg games double I are not
everyone's favorite but in bullet Jets
especially they are they are things that
you wish you could just like literally
give away right because you'd rather
have the open lines the open FI files
and diagonals in bullet to give you some
tactics so I I agree um uh Magnus much
better in game two you called it fuu
started out with a three-oh lead earlier
this week if Magnus reverses that script
you could have Carlson Nakamura in a
final I mean he's just cruising right
now this Knight is going to on D5 in the
near future like right now our rookie
won first okay I don't know if it
matters so much but he brings his Knight
don't take the bishop because Knight F6
check the queen would still protect the
bishop on C6 Magnus he drops the C2 Pawn
though and that gives ala some new life
yeah and he's got the bishop here now
one is off the board but still this is
much closer to equal peruja also playing
faster this game still down on the clock
but not nearly the deficit it was in
game one go although as I say that uhoh
as I say that it's going the other way
fu shaking his
head and again not not calling calling
anyone out in any way but I am calling
the momentum out Magnus has already won
a match today he's looking fresh feeling
fresh in his home environment fuja looks
a little tired just going to be honest
right he doesn't look as uh as fresh as
he did earlier in the week so we'll see
if he can shake off whatever is uh
whatever the fogs are or he's facing a
three deficit maybe he needs Fabby to
show up and tell him he's looking fresh
because some people are the recipient of
that comment others they never get it
but for fuer doesn't matter what we say
it matters what he does and here he is
the white pieces and Danny he's worse
once again look at Black's Army in the
center so good you you nailed it on that
by the way so by the way Fabby is
looking fresh and I just want to say
that again um all right yeah the Pawns
in the center pressure on the king you
always say bullet King safety even more
relevant right because you don't have
the time to work yourself out of a bind
that's an important trade there for fuia
to get get some of the tactics out of
the way but look at this Magnus just
rolling still up on the clock again by
four seconds this is this is a different
Magnus Carlson and we know hiar Nakamura
is
watching what are we gonna have here if
Magnus moves on to the final I mean you
saw what the arrows I just drew there's
at some point going to be an attack on
the diagonal going for Queen H2 mate
like right now he goes Queen E5 que E5
right now ah but he allowed the queen
train that was an inaccuracy for Magnus
for sure for sure that's a huge huge
moment and this might be a huge save
verua needs to stop the bleeding you
don't want to fall down three 0 Magnus
wasn't able to recover from that earlier
he needs to hold this game but Magnus is
slightly ahead in the clock so he should
use as a weapon and honestly I think
Magnus what he should do is avoid losing
that sounds like duh you never want to
lose but you do not want to give ala
that confidence so he's locked the
position up and he's going for a win oh
my gosh look at the pawns look at the
king Magnus Carlson
wants the 3oh start that fua gave him
earlier this week returning the
favor look at this also again he's still
but look at F he cut the king
off yeah that was brilliant with the
rook and I'm looking at time but it's
coming down to time oh my gosh and is
blunder apparently but not much time for
either
player there is no time Magnus on a king
run wants to flag him but look at fua
flexing the better time scramble skills
and DCH is in the chat what's up Dan
saying that magus's form is a 100 times
today what it was yesterday but fua just
showed off the mouse speed and that's
the annoying thing when someone has a
rook and you just have a bishop Bishops
can't deliver checks when the king is on
the opposite color the Rooks can just
pester you across the board and that
King was cut off so limited movement for
magnus's pieces and oliv Raza better
with black in this
game yeah I love it and it's a really
instructive point for bullet the idea
that The Rook is just an easier piece to
play with there than the bishop the
bishop was constantly worried about
blundering right moving to the wrong
Square The Rook The Rook was in a
dominant spot which allowed fuia to
pre-move his way back into a Time
Advantage so interesting stuff
um all
right Magnus still has a game lead but
fuia seems to have found it a little bit
yep I can read between the lines here
what you're seeing this game is not the
most interesting bullet game we've seen
today you can hear that in my voice just
like my voice goes higher when I'm
insecure oh BL heed the queen mag
blundered the fork look at look at the
Bob the music we obviously are gonna ask
Magnus what he's listening to No No
matter how he finishes on the
day I mean that was actually a potential
match changing blunder because yeah Al
was up a paon he was better and there
was no risk in the position except he
fell into a night fork and that happens
in bullet chess watch out for the
knights note that Magnus didn't walk
into the fork on E2 there with that nice
King H2 move very smart flexing the
rook's dominance over the night he's
going to take a 20- lead fuja doesn't
waste any time on the clock gets right
back at it yeah 3 to one in magnus's
favor right now two point spread as you
mentioned and so we see it's now kakan
time and Ali Raza he's a proponent of
the kakan and this is just a weird
opening this Knight on C6 came from G8
like how do you explain that to
somebody sorry I love that comment from
Dar scribe what would be spooky is if
Magnus said he wasn't listening to any
music anyway that would be that would be
awesome by the way the chat did say
Magnus Carlson is the favorite here 54%
to 46% thanks for voting chat um we'll
see if you're
right I what's right is this position
for black like oh what a tactic that
Knight could be captured in two ways but
the Knight was pinned on the diagonal
and then when you capture the queen look
at all of Black's Army and white has a
limited one and by the way look at E5
what a strong move to flex the center
knowing that you can't take that pawn
without opening up lines for The Rook
especially in bullet you don't want your
king to come under Fire so Magnus Magnus
as D just said his form is fire today oh
and look at this H4 move where's the
queen going F6 is next you couldn't play
F6 because the queen was in touch with
G6 now oh he gets Queen into F2 Queen E1
he just steal the materi missed that you
saw his response he didn't even see
Queen F2 and he loses the Knight and
he's uh he's feeling the pain right now
I I sorry ala I didn't see that either
but Magnus did and that's all that's
important because Magnus is Curly out to
a three-point lead this is a complete
roll reversal of their first
match yeah yeah we will ask Magnus to
share his playlist he could he'll he'll
do that at some point we'll see if he's
willing um all right yeah Magnus has
completely turned this around in terms
of how he played earlier this week but
fua still has time if he can we know
what he's capable of here he goes tricks
here for
black watch out for Queen H4 uh oh Queen
H4 what so black has two minor pieces
for a rook and a pawn but black has this
Knight entrenched on E3 and it's not
going anywhere unless you trade off and
the next Knight might be able to replace
it but Magnus fighting well but ala
quicker on the clock yeah but this is
the kind of game fuia needed here this
is a turnaround he's up on the clock
he's better on the board this is
probably the best game we've seen him
play so far we'll see if he can convert
it he better I mean don't fall for any
tactics this these moves for black have
all been good the knight's Wheeling into
E3 yeah this is just great play for
ala yeah up a piece 20 minutes on the
clock everyone take a breath I I expect
this one to be
close Collective breath breae in into
your diaphragm because that sends a
message from your brain that tells your
body it's okay to relax I've learned
that like a human thingy your your brain
your brain works oh I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding sorry D I had to I had to
I'm
sorry it tells your brain to relax which
I need to do often for my brain um to
remind it to keep working I feel bad now
I I just I've got to be honest I feel
bad I'm I feel I feel great about this I
love the r vers are here you're hosting
you're roasting you're doing it all I
love it did you just go full walk Fraser
on me you know hey still got still got a
few a few tricks in the bag um all right
well fu is up a piece but Magnus flexing
that he's got a three- game lead he's
going to get as much time off the clock
as he can um peruja you know again
winning and up seconds I don't expect
this one to go any other direction but a
but a fua
wi yep and hting and roasting for the
boys
that mag magnets looked a little bit
bothered by that defeat and you he was
able to rebound immediately the last
time around but we'll see in this game
as he goes back to what seems to be his
trusty
kokan yeah he's playing the kokan but
fuja with a better position I think if
this one goes Fu's way and he wins two
games in a row for the first time today
uh I don't know that Magnus is going to
keep going back to the kocan just
prediction but this does look pretty
awesome for black I mean white has these
terrible pawns his bad Bishop on G2
all white is was looking better yeah
I've seen better Bishop pairs in my
life yeah yeah some of the moves come in
chat so fast that it you can't keep up
right because they are literally playing
at human speeds that are faster than the
broadcast technology literally like like
we can complain about it but the reality
is they're playing chess faster than
than we can sometimes keep up with
that's just the truth um we should
celebrate it for being incredible we
should celebrate it and barua should
celebrate this position although I'll
say this the eval bar doesn't tell the
story of how tricky this is Magnus has
two knights the white king is open I see
hes nodding along that always feels good
to this low self-esteem International
Master when he agrees with me well thank
you for that um and uh okay but I you
agree right this is trickier for fuia
than the eval Bar says this is a blunder
spot but I'm looking at the clock and
Magnus is given up yeah and the g file
yeah H6 by the way was an awesome move
cuz if the king took on H6 the queen
would have traded on D2 and that's why
Magus took the pawn but he lost the game
and now it's back to a closer match so
Ali
Raza he scored a couple wins there and
what is this from we're get like
a what it wasn't wasn't a bon Cloud
which I'm hoping for anyone who follows
me on Twitter tweeted a little little
Bon Cloud earlier today but uh oh issue
page five that's an exchange did Magnus
just miss that he did but you know
what's funny about that is he still has
like a ton of comp compensation because
the bishop can't move from f8 and now
that you've castled Queen side maybe
white can try to drum up some pressure
over
there that's a nice move F5 forces on
assant which is you got a rook you got
to open files and that's what fuja will
need to flex The Exchange advantage and
look at this he's I mean if if a third
win in a row happens and we are
deadlocked at four you know call your
friends we keep saying it it's Friday
take off work it's already afternoon
where most of you are so let's go
yep Magnus is doing his best he's trying
to play quickly and just pose a few
problems and he's going after the H7
Pawn if he can trade the king side off
that gives him better
chances yeah he wants to keep the Queens
on the board get something going with an
attack I like Queen E6 look
at that was amazing
geometry yeah we always say retreating
moves are the hardest to spot especially
with no time
perua put putting on a clinic here of
how to convert an extra Exchange in
bullet and by the way okay I was going
to say he's not too down on the clock he
is down 4 seconds
though Ria is the future Fu Ali freaking
fuja has tied this match yeah he said
hand down man down that's Checkmate in
the corner and that was sweet from Fu
that was an excellent game he has won
three in a row it hit the turkey if you
like bowling um but look at this
position now Magnus as you said when
you've double isolate pawns get rid of
them because it opens up the space for
the rest of your pieces and both players
they're playing this very quickly such a
weird
position yeah this is one that it's like
every move looks like a blunder does
Rook C8 not win a piece I mean like I
don't know what's going on here like but
uh the players are are holding their own
especially with uh okay only 15 minutes
left and we are tied even with magnus's
fast start this one is going to come
down to the wire and let's remember fans
you have to win by two in the new BCC
format which I love and uh make sure
that it has us here to the very end I'm
looking at the clock Ali Rea is up
several seconds he's also up a pawn this
is another game that's going other Razer
F's way and he needs to not let up
Knight C5 that one a piece I think oh
but that one's an exchange so he wins
the game Magnus is
tilting yeah he's frustrated he's about
to lose his fourth game in a row we saw
him kind of uh take a beat and take a
breath and then take a swig of water
right sometimes that's the hardest thing
to do in these online formats Robert is
just gather yourself right because
there's no there's no time to shake off
the emotional effects of of of a bad
loss and uh and Magnus has got to get
his head right here Ali Resa fuja has
won four games in a row if you're just
joined and sometimes when you lose a
Time scramble like Magnus did when he
had a bishop and a bunch of pawns for a
rook is you start getting worried that
in future time scrambles you'll also be
the slower player so that was a huge win
in that game from Ali Rea not just on
the scoreboard but whoa Magnus is giving
up a piece for two Central pawns
here I was about to say great then I was
like is it tilt Magnus sacrifices a
piece from a practical perspective you
kind of like White's chances even if the
engine is saying that black is better
but look at that move leaving the
tension pinning the Knight on B3 and so
Magnus pass pawns they got to start
rolling but this Knight's not going to
slide into E6 to stop the pass D Pawn
it's a bluff the pck was a bluff the
pawns are going nowhere Magnus Carlson
could be losing his fifth game in a
row he needs Denny oh that was a huge
blunder he let the knights get traded
he's lost yep it's over now and now he
needs to resigned and get back at it he
needs to learn the lesson that uh that
he gave that he gave da in the last
match don't waste extra
time he's take on F4 take on E5 that's a
winning king of Pawn in game and yeah he
needs to write the ship right now
because fuja has suddenly been able to
overtake Carlson on the scoreboard it's
a two-point fua lead at the moment 6 to4
mag was up 4 to
one
y six to
four Magnus Carlson has lost five games
in a row but you're seeing why Alie resa
fua is the only other person to win a
bullet chest championship title besides
AAR Nakamura right this guy this guy
even starting slow something woke him up
whatever it was and uh he's a monster he
is and he's just playing principal chess
right now but the thing I like about
magnus's very bizarre opening is that
he's up on time so sometimes it's okay
to play Bad moves and bullet as long as
you play those bad moves
quickly yeah the balance of uh don't
don't play so bad that you lose but uh
but make sure you have an edge on the on
the clock when it matters as I like to
say the key to winning chess games is to
play the best moves fast whoa there's a
knight on D7 you almost never see
that Rook d8 though what what is the
deal Knight C2 but now you lose the
piece oh Knight F6 check is a big threat
how do you stop that Magnus is and you
see him dejected there he reacts Knight
F6 check is going to be mate with the
Rooks on the defile and perua is going
to win his sixth game in a row bullet is
a is a game of momentum more than
anything else and fuja is on fire right
now this has been exceptional to witness
and fuja it looked like he was shaky at
the start and he's saying no I'm just
getting warmed up Magnus had that warm
up against da and now here in this match
it feels like ala the wor worst uh of
his chess he got it out early that's
really good news he needs to keep this
up though because if Magnus gets one win
you know he smells blood he's able to
win several in a
row yeah Greg shahadi said it it's been
a brutal 10 minutes for Magnus Carlson
but there is still 10 minutes left in
the match so if he can pull it together
he has time this this is still though
looking like a lot of pressure from
peruja whoa did he sack oh it was made
on G3 that was glorious that was
glorious it was yeah that's such an easy
thing to overlook and well Magnus has a
better Pawn structure he's playing
against these doubled C pawns but for
now Al R has more activity until
G4 what's going on here G4 might be a
move you don't want to play especially
because he was up on the clock by a
second there was no reason to rush
Magnus getting maybe a little bit
frustrated
here whoa he's going to trade look at
the light Square dominance what an
interesting spot to be in down a pawn
but potentially better in the end game
and it's a big problem why you've double
pawns if these Pawn One Pawn was in the
B file you'd be able to create a passer
look at that move C4 if you take now
your Pawn structure is permanently awful
and now white should just go oh why is
he allowing the king
ining but he was threat he was
threatening Bishop G5 but fui should
have taken that
chance this is actually a very dangerous
game for Magnus because with time going
off the clock you could lose you're
going to lose a lot of time in the
overall match here fuja should play
don't take the draw oh that was a
practical mistake for sure by fuja but
Magnus was up two and a half seconds so
that's why fuja felt compelled to take
that draw so I'm with you that was a
winning end game and he probably felt
that it should be but he looked at his
clock and that's what Magnus did better
he didn't play his best game far from it
and you said this in the beginning of
the show when we looked at DA's accuracy
versus magnus's it's not always
important to play the most accurate
moves cuz if you're doing it slowly
you're probably going to get a flag down
the stretch and what is Magnus doing
didn't he just drop the B5 Pawn yeah he
did and he yelled at himself he said oh
come on man and he you could see he said
it and uh at least he drew the last game
so he has stopped the bleeding quote
unquote but that was a horrible
blunder barua has uh has pushed him
perhaps on on tilt here f is a tough
opponent for anybody and he is unbeaten
the last seven games is there a mate no
that evil bar was Skyhigh and now it's
going back down and black suddenly has
play on The Queen side
yeah fua probably missed some sort of
version of a of a win there that a pawn
is dangerous oh but a PA's gone Magnus
might be might be losing it though okay
oh is it oh wait this is just no it's
king D7 but where's the beef where's the
mate just win the material he's up a
piece right
now and Magnus is faster look at it he's
up six plus seconds at the moment oh and
the evaluation bar is going down because
you can't keep this E5 pawn and now what
black should do is take the G Pawn if
you could take the G Pawn the chess.com
server says you make a draw so Bishop F3
Play Bishop F3 Bishop F3 and it's a draw
he's trying to win find it he's trying
to
win he can't no maybe doesn't have a
choice yeah because of the match
situation but you can't win this game
don't take the Knight that
loses all right so he is up now he's
really in trouble well mag flag
him
peruja put the pawn on a dark Square
though that was super
smart Ving the Bishop from doing
anything but it still should be a draw
well if ala can somehow out speed Magnus
then there could be a winning chance but
no Magnus is just going to keep his King
in front of the pawn and we are likely
to see any second now and there's the
draw 1.5 that was way closer than I
thought it would be yeah but in a huge
in a huge uh practical win for peruja
because so much time came off the clock
there only six minutes and 50 seconds
left and Magnus is facing a three-game
deficit yeah he's up the pace has Magnus
Carlson he knows that he needs to win
and probably win quickly he still has
enough time there's 6 minutes and 40
seconds remaining in the match so he
doesn't have to go all in just yet but
he needs to get two games wins for him
and not lose
anymore yeah and for roua is just
focused I mean he is uh he's not he's
not giving an right
now he's not and he's going for the good
old mating pattern King H1 what a smart
move by Magus he also gets out of this
pin so Bishop G4 will be met by Pawn
F3 yeah and he goes for it puts the
Knight on e4 Magnus turning it around
again as you said there is time but you
have to start winning if you win this
game you've got time to win another so
don't blunder Don't Panic yeah that's
really good life advice in general so
everybody out there don't blunder Don't
Panic don't panic but but it's
hard it's really difficult to like keep
your composure and Magnus has been
playing fast but look at that all of a
sudden ala he's on the
offensive I would say if there was one
difference right now in the match and I
I know it's not over yet is fua has just
had more pressure against against
magnus's King in most positions he's
been the one attacking the king and from
a practical point of view that has led
to some blunders although right as I say
that Magnus flipping the script on that
queens and knights coming after the King
on G8 oh look at this he wants Knight F6
he and he gets it because he cut the he
gets Knight F6 he put the pawn on D6 to
interpose along the sixth Rank and right
now Magnus has to stop worrying about
his clock I sorry about the position and
worry about the clock he needs to flag
ol Razer here he is up a second but he's
burning
clock oh yeah and I wonder if he had D7
there but yeah he does have time Knight
H6 oh just pre D6 the Pieces come off
you've got to pre moove the Knight
doesn't matter just you can lose pieces
just be faster than your
opponent did he did he blunder that KN
for a second maybe he did no he did look
at that but that's the thing you that's
the right thing to do like DA has done
this many times you just give away all
your pieces and just pre-move at that
point and he wins on the clock with four
seconds to spare and now it's just a
two-point
margin yep yeah it's a really great
Point Robert because at a certain point
you do the math even a pre moove loses a
point second on the clock right that's
the fastest you can play on chess.com is
a .1 second and
so you know at a certain point you do
the math and all you have to do is free
move to flag your opponent right yeah
and also when you take a pawn you expect
your opponent to pre-move the recapture
so your opponent the per like ala took
the pawn on B before he expects Magnus
to recapture on B4 but mag Magus doesn't
so he's not anticipating that he could
take this Knight on C3 next and that
sort of shocks you so I think that you
just pre-move in those situations and
now Magnus he won the last game look at
this position up a few seconds
dominating the queen side with control
of the the C file and white is cramped
that Bishop on C2 is a glorified Pawn
Yeah and remember you have to win by two
so if Magnus wins one more game he's
already in that spot where if time ran
out he would still be be uh having a
fighter chance here yes and he's got a
great position right now even material
uh the bishop finally gets out and it's
traded and he wants a pass Pawn Magnus
keeping the lead on the clock Danny this
is a different Magnus than earlier in
the match he's changed his strategy to
just be faster than
ala yeah playing faster and by the way
he's kind of playing better while
playing faster so right now if he wins
this game and we are back within one uh
the uh the route is not there oh but
look at wow what a nice trick that
Knight is coming into F5 that Rook is
running out of squares oh my God he's
holding the Rook with the
king Crazy position King C4 traps
trapped on D3 okay he gets a square on
F3 it's an ugly square but here again
Magnus just has to move it doesn't have
to be perfect chess the evaluation may
go in Al R's favor but just go just go
takes the night wins a piece forja going
for tricks but we have a onepoint match
everybody call Mom tell her to tune
in mom the meat Lo
no I'm watching twitch on
chess oh my goodness it's a one-point
match and look at this position both
sides with doubled C pawns and this is a
weird position but I could see an
exchange sack on D5 at some moment yeah
and I can see black not wanting to take
it and playing C6 but okay the Rooks
come off the board B6 is played some
doubled pawns only a mother could love
for both players doubled C pawns this is
one that almost feels like a a take a
breath game for both players Robert like
all right match has been set the stage
has been set Magnus shows he's not going
away um and uh this one is probably
going to end and peacefully probably but
as I'm looking at the clock yeah you're
right like is Magnus trying to lock up
the position and then he strikes with F4
I was about say at the right moment
strike and then F5 and then things get a
little bit complicated H5 becomes weak
he'll play Knight G2 here probably just
hold on he does but at some point F5
comes oh barua forces the issue but E5
and F5 who's getting there a huge
mistake oh my God and Magus up seconds
and his pass pawns are mobile whereas
his Knight blocks the enemy pass this is
just the pawns are pushing up the board
and I think white is taking this
game it's funny the Panic there by fuia
was something we haven't really seen
today but I think he looked at the clock
didn't want Magnus to grind him Robert
whoa was that a mistake how do you break
through if your Magnus Knight F6 to D7
just
Queen he goes for it Knight F6 but eight
but there's H2 but Knight D7 and you get
your queen with mate
uhuh oh my gosh it's going to be a tide
match yeah and look at fou is like all
right all
right here we go tied match less than a
minute to play we're going to overtime
boys and girls buckle up it's sudden
death dodgeball but the players better
remember that because it's easy to
forget it's win by two and so you may
get really frustrated you know may get
very emotional but this is not a Do or
Die moment it's not going to be good for
other player to lose but you're
tournament run is not over if you do in
fact lose this game
Y what a what a match of momentum this
has been Robert Magnus up 4-1 fuja wins
five six games in a row almost right who
and now Magnus turning it
around what is happening he might be
about to win his what is well this will
be his fourth game in a row if he wins
this yeah he was down by three and now
it's even so it would be the fourth win
and he is better with the black pieces
look at his uh fluidity and the pie is
all doing something but the bishop B3
that scares you even if it doesn't
actually threaten
anything nice use of
fluidity thank you my friend all right
here we go momentum in this match is
crazy the uh it's funny right as I said
that fuja has been the one with most
attacking chances I feel like that
turned around and Magnus has been
putting a little more pressure on wh
King you said he's been playing faster
that's the consistent thing that's
changed now he's up again
Magnus Carlson has turned this thing
around and now he's bobbing his head to
music again baruja needs to find it and
oh the rook's trapped to so Bishop G4 is
coming oh my
gosh all right time is out but it's win
by two does fuia know that he's looking
at the
clock yeah he does he's he's locked in
he does and this is it if Magnus wins
this it's over oh my goodness it's
overtime it's free ch
don't go anywhere this is exciting stuff
and for Magnus Carlson he has won four
games in a row but right now he's
sacrificed two pawns at the moment he's
playing a Gambit
line playing a Gambit line he's going
for it he wants the
kill aruja in a good spot though the
king is out of the center no longer in
danger what is this Knight F6 and D5 so
okay the but you said no longer in
danger the black king is worse than the
white king even though Black's up a pawn
so I like mag
slight lead on the clock and the fact
that he's no longer down material yeah
and fua is shaking his head but again
even if he draws this game he's still in
the match so fuja has got to gather
himself keep his Focus so this is a rook
end game essentially with Queens this
should be a draw objectively if the best
chess is played fuja needs to play fast
and hold on wow what a spot there by
Magnus by the way because Queen B check
you can play Queen E5 like now mag you
play for a win you are up 10 seconds you
flag your opponent
yeah fuia has got to find a way to to
trick Magnus here because Magnus is
going to flag him to move on to the
Grand Final and get knock more this is
it you got you got you got to change
change what's happening here this is
scary territory for ala but we need to
keep count on the 50 move rule at some
point Magnus might need to play the move
F5 even if it's bad just to try to win
on time because right now Al has Perfect
Defense objectively the position is
equal yep and peruja doing exactly what
you would do in both classical and
bullet hold this game a master class if
he can hold on yes 13 seconds to make 50
moves basically okay but now he's going
The Rook F6 and if you're Magnus oh
that's great play from
fuja wow the defense the defense from
fuia Magnus loses his opportunity to
flag him and that might be something
that comes back to haunt him if peruja
ultimately turns it around yeah earlier
in this competition the first first day
of action Anish G lost a match to Jose
Martinez it went to overtime Anish was
up by one and he couldn't secure match
Victory and then Jose was able to take
over so this game here if ala can win it
all of a sudden we're back to a tied
match and I have to say the way that
Magnus just played in that last game it
looked really good it looked promising
but then you get a bit deflated that you
didn't convert totally agree the
psychological Edge has suddenly shifted
back to fuja here even though he's down
a game I completely agree if fuja gets
this one and he does have an
edge we we've seen this match swing
wildly if you're just tuning in where
have you been your mom has been calling
saying go watch the chess match on
Twitch it's totally lit and now you're
here and uh and
fua why did the evaluation bar go so
high there that was
surprising there's like a like a rook C1
or the queen was trapped after Rook C1
for that's what I I was just guessing
but yeah the queen had no squares that
was nutty okay but that's helpful this
again the engine really helps us because
you think it's a normal position and
suddenly with one bad move it's winning
for aside and what is happening here H6
fell but a pass deep pawn and open C
file who's
better yeah I I kind of like magnus's
chances here although I will say this
fuja has sped up no longer the deficit
on the time though right as I say that
right as I say that got to play Fast
Magnus is in a position to flag and win
the match uh oh you know what this
reminds me of that candidates game
between Ding and aaru like complete
chaos one side attacking one side with a
pass pawn and right now this Pawn looks
very scary and if he gets his Rook to
the first rank he can win this game but
the evaluation still Level and Magnus up
a couple
seconds what and now he's threatening
rookie one I'm like I'm freaking out
this could be the match could be the
moment B Pawn goes but the the bishop
was hanging so he had to go here and now
there's Rook
A7 7 Seconds to 4 seconds Here Comes F5
oh but the Rook was coming to A1 yes you
got to get checks this could be the
match and if if you're all is if you can
get the Rook off the board oh he BL it I
was oh got no he drew it Magnus blew it
oh my gosh that was the match oh my gosh
I was about to finish my sense and if he
can get the Rook it clears the way to a
draw and Ali Raza he is faster when they
just have a couple seconds on the clock
and that is why he's still
alive but I feel like Magnus panicked
there didn't he have time not to lose
the Rook or no peruja had gotten the on
the clock my God oh my goodness fja
what's fan doing why did you just spend
all that time there I was going to say
fuja fighting for his life but yeah
mismanaging the clock here down by 10
whole seconds that's like like a piece
and bullet although that Rook might be a
trap piece if you're not careful but
look at this he gives up the exchange to
win two pawns and have a rook on the
seventh rank Magnus he sniffed this out
from a while back yeah that was sneak
that was
sneaky the only thing I'll say is that
Rooks dude if Rooks get going though and
bullet that's the only thing I'll
say but look at PA those passers can you
check and play
G6 Jack play G6 or just put the bishop
on D3 and get it out of the way push him
yeah he does it I like that push him
baby yep but but baruja holding on but
the the lead on the clock for Magnus I
think that might even be the worst part
of this not only are there two pass pun
supp by Bishop and kick who he resigned
seconds early and fuja leans back and
Magnus is celebrating he knows he's
going to take
it oh my go gosh that's it Magnus moves
on to the Grand Final and he's dancing
into a match up against AAR
Nakamura wow it came to a close so fast
and Magnus Carlson talking to whoever
from our team is uh is enjoying the
victory enjoys the water
what a crazy turnaround what a crazy
swinging wild ride that was for oi Resa
fua at one point he had a three game
lead he can't hold
on and he takes third place I feel for
him look at him he's so confused about
what just happened he was winning that
match he had won five games in a row and
Magnus Carlson no longer at the world
champion in classical chess but the
world rapid and World Blitz champion and
now wants to add the bullet chest
Champion to his list of world so Danny
that was one of the matches that you
dreamed to have you just it's a
privilege to witness and have the call
for it and Magnus Carlson he barely
squeaks by Ali Raza fuan overtime and I
just have to say one more time for Ali
Raza like I feel for him he played so
well throughout the
match you feel for him Peru's got 40,000
fans watching between YouTube and twitch
people are here on a Friday this is
awesome though I mean you got to you got
to applaud for 's effort there and
again felt like he had it but what a
crazy match that was if it was it was a
real wild swing for both players but it
shows what momentum can do for you and
Magnus takes it by two games in
overtime what a match that was and for
Magnus it's already been two great match
victories and his day is not done
because with that win over ala fua
Magnus goes up he levitates to the Grand
Final against Hikaru Nakamura so Danny I
mean that was a great match we're wowed
by it but we got to talk about what's
about to happen yeah no I mean I guess
this is the match that most people want
to see whenever these two guys throw
down the internet tends to stop and tune
in the world tends to stop and tune in
when Nakamura goes up against Carlson
I'm gonna say I think hikaro is the
favorite here again not just because
he's he's won a whole bunch of these
events but I you know hikaro sent fuja
to the losers bracket for a reason right
won that match by by by four games in
the end and Magnus is going to have to
once again he had to up his game moving
from da to Ali Reza he's going to need
to up his game again moving from Ali
Resa to Nakamura if he's going to have a
chance here well I'm not sure if it's
good news for Magnus or not but they up
the time limit 45 minutes rather than 30
30 minutes a bullet when you get back
into the Grand Final so that is going to
be on the flip side of the break but
before we do go to break and hopefully
get an interview just want to shout out
that if you've been wanting to try out
chess.com premium features before
committing to a membership now is the
time in honor of yesterday's
International Chess Day cash in on 30
days premium for free enjoy a full month
of unlimited puzzles lessons game review
and more this offer ends on July 27th so
don't miss your chance use the command
claim in chat to unlock 30 days of
premium Now Danny we just saw some great
chess hopefully people get access to
Great features we will not have an
interview but when we return it's aaru
it's Magnus it's the matchup that the
people want and the people are going to
get be right
back what's the best way to follow any
chess event from the Champions chess
tour to the candidates speed chess
championship title Tuesday Fay world
championship and so much more chess.com
events has all of the top chess
tournaments played both over the board
and online analyze and review games from
the world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more even
compete by voting for your predicted
results explore chess.com events today
on web or with our IOS and Android apps
and experience chess like never before
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com connect your chess.com account
and Twitch account at go. chess.com
connect accounts and bang boom voila
you're done 100% adree Bliss forever
more whether you're following our events
on site or on stream type the command
connect in the chat and thank you for
helping bring these shows to life
[Music]
a
oh 97 97 he misses the fork he's good
man he's good he can take on D5 with
check and the problem is now he has no M
attack he's got to turn the game around
just given up his bishop and he's given
up what's going on
here captured and he's getting M mates
he's thinking about winning when he's
losing and then he's going to demoralize
you when he does that Andrew quickly
winning a couple games in a row that is
really important for him oh my gosh he
allowed a Checkmate as soon as I said
winning a couple games he gets it done
again just reminds us uh Robert why he's
on top of the bullet world
[Music]
you heard Maurice Ashley say it he
demoralizes you because even when he's
in trouble he still gets the job done
and wins he's a car Nakamura and he's a
man on a mission and Danny he's been
unbelievable thus far in the
BCC he sure has and obviously uh Magnus
Carlson has been unbelievable today but
now he's running up against is the guy
who is unbelievable every day in bullet
and this guy's margin of Victory speaks
for itself there's a reason he's the one
waiting in the Grand Final and uh we'll
see we'll see what Magnus is capable of
against the king of bullet here and uh
I'm ready hey if you can't miss when
you're going after the King right the
wire they taught us that and for Magnus
Carlson he's been the King of Chess for
so long but when it comes to Bullet I
mean Hikaru is just a beast he's a
three-time champ in this event he also
has been just absolutely dominant
throughout this year's bullet chest
Championship so it's just so so
impressive yeah and uh you know
obviously he's been watching Magnus
today so I think the one thing Magnus
has going for him is in terms of most
recent memory Magnus Just Beat Da he
just beat all Resa fua there's momentum
obviously on his side of the Court here
and uh if if Magnus can get off to a
good start and keep that momentum going
maybe maybe that pushes hikaro off his
off his form right so I think that
really the beginning of this match is
huge for Magnus and for hikaro to show
hey I don't have any rust I know Magnus
has been playing but I'm ready to start
off on the right track yeah Magnus has
been playing and pretty much everything
he's played in recently has been a great
success we have some highlights from
magnus's recent success at the aess
rapid take a
look should be doing everything right
but not anymore he blundered his night
and this is how it's
done oh I was worried about I was
worried about Rook F4 what's happening
here oh my gosh it King G5 found it oh
my God not's in trouble Magnus knows it
he just gave you the Magnus like nod oh
look at that oh my gosh yeah he's losing
right here and N loses on the clock and
there it looking finishing it off in
style and Magnus takes it because it
gets him the match Victory what a match
performance this has been by the world
number one oh hello seconds
the wow Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces delivers Checkmate oh my God and
we have a winner Magnus Carson
checkmates Wesley so and wins the a
chest
rid Magnus Carlson wins that is a
sentence that we hear very often the
five-time Fay classical world champion
he gave away his title he didn't even
play dingl Ren became the new world
champion but Magnus he's the rning
champion in the world rapid the world
Blitz but his first Fay into the bullet
chest championship and Danny he's going
right into the jungle into the lion Den
where he's going to face off against AAR
Nakamura well you see all those uh those
titles there this isn't officially a
bullet World Championship because we're
not allowed to call it that um but if
you want to call it a bullet Global
Championship you can call it that it's
basically this is who the best bullet
chess player in the world is and Magnus
Carlson has a lot of titles he doesn't
have this one bullet is an online game
right and that's the reality right if
you tried to play bullet without
increment over the board other things
happen right so this is this is it this
is Magnus Carlson versus hiar Nakamura
who is the best bullet player on the
planet and uh I think I think he wants
this title and uh we'll we'll see
remember he has to beat hikaro twice
right because Hikaru is the one waiting
so you got to win and then you got to
win again in overtime and we know when
these two guys are capable of as far as
uh bringing the fans in we see
viewership going up at the break Robert
that's how you know we're in for a treat
people are like stop what you're doing
Morpheus is fighting Neo let's go I do
remember the speed chest championship
between these two it went down to the
wire Magnus won the last game but he was
still one point behind this is a win by
two format so if the time elapses and
you're within a point hey the G the
match continues and as you said Magnus
has to beat hi car twice he needs to win
the 45 minutes in the Grand Final then
he if he wins that he needs to win 30
minutes of the reset so this going to be
a tough task you're playing a car
Nakamura he is such a monster he's a
three-time champ of this event and so
far hikaru's been seemingly Unstoppable
and he looked throughout his bullet
career on chess.com Peak rating 3570 but
what's I think most interesting for me
Danny look at how rarely hi car wins by
flag but that might just be because his
opponent's
resign yeah that's a interesting stat I
I I don't even know what to make of that
because um you would think he's just as
good at flagging people as someone like
da and has played enough games um to uh
to think that that stat might be higher
but yeah maybe it's the Hikaru factor
maybe people resign when they're losing
and he's so fast that they just see
there's no chance so obviously you see
12,000 games way more than Magnus but
not as much as Don niski who played
30,000 games um and the accuracy is so
close between these two guys so uh what
else can you say right it's a coin flip
in many respects um I think we both
agree hikaro might be the slight
favorite but I also think that I speak
for a lot of fans and that I wouldn't be
upset if we got a second round right if
Magnus Carlson won the first and we get
more chess because who wants this thing
to end this is amazing it's so much fun
nobody wants it to end except for Hikaru
he would like to end it in the first
match and I just want to say a day ago
if you asked me to make a prediction I
would say that Hikaru was a sizable
favorite Barcelona Magnus much worse
than Norway Magnus the Magnus that we
saw today I me that's phenomenal form he
beat da and it was convincing in the end
and da had high praise for Magnus then
Magnus goes on to lose like six games in
a row I can't even remember it was
happening so fast my memory I'm like a
goldfish I'm like Ted lasso taught me to
be I cannot remember what just happened
but I do remember that Ali Rizza was
just blitzing Magnus winning all these
games and then Magnus still won the
match have you can you remember a match
where someone lost so many games in a
row and still won I was just going to
say that I think that in some ways that
almost plays in his favor that he had
his back against the wall and survived
right almost even better Robert than if
he had beaten Oli Resa in a dominant
fashion because we know that you got to
take your punches when it comes to
facing Hikaru you know he's going to
land a few right Hikaru Nakamura is
going to land some punches because he's
damn good at what he does and the fact
that Magnus is now a little more battle
tested and and survived that that
three-game deficit to fuia if you're
just tuning in I think that makes him
even more dangerous here against taru
and 45 minutes means there's even more
time to kind of recover from a slide if
you have one and for Hikaru he could
have been prepping as you see Magnus on
the screen in front of you and a big
question is was that warmup helpful or
is Magnus potentially tired now and for
Hikaru was resting good for him or was
he not getting into the form that he
needs to be maybe he'll be slow at the
gate what do you think Danny about this
upcoming Final I mean I think you're
you're asking the right questions right
I think that that'll be that'll be what
we see is hiar Rusty and Magnus on a
roll I here's what I do think I think
the 45 minute extra time we have for the
final which is a pretty cool thing I'm
glad that we did that means that either
way Robert the best bullet chest is
going to win in the end I think that we
might see some rust from Hikaru you
might see you might see Magnus maybe
stumble a little bit but he'll have
enough time to recover and get himself
refocused although as I say that now I'm
like as the day goes on does momentum
become exhaustion right and that's the
risk for Magnus Carlson is that he has
to win twice and he's already won two
matches today can he keep it going as
you said he needs to win twice if he
does win the 45-minute match it resets
and then it's 30 minutes of bullet chess
the winner is crowned the 2023 bullet
chess champion they had $220,000 and
whoever loses this match still walks
away with 16 Grand not a bad prize fund
at all $100,000 in total prizes across
the bullet Chess Championship I'm just
excited for them to start I'm going to
be real I don't want to talk to you
anymore I love you Danny we're super
close friends I just want to watch them
play Hey I'm with you you know what let
no more talk a little more action let's
go by the way speaking of action chat
voted and uh it's even closer than the
other two as it should be 52% of you say
hikaro Nakamura is the favorite heading
into this match again that's about as
close as it can get to a 50-50 split so
uh here we
go CaRu Nakamura Magnus
Carlson God those words feel
good it certainly do and what is this
Mainline stuff why are they playing a
long theoretical variation where they
barely spent any time and we're on move
21 and they're trading off all the
pieces yeah maybe a little bit of nerves
maybe neither side wanted to play to
risk it for the biscuit chess out of the
gate and uh now hikaro a little worried
about his back rank that makes
sense and this seeing more pieces get
traed and also from a Time perspective
they've played so fast that neither
player should really get in in the kind
of time pressure that leads to blunders
although now things going a little bit
wh's Direction hiar accepts The Rook
ending and interesting he offered a
trade but Magnus doesn't want to trade
because the white king is close to the
center this is actually instructive
stuff you don't say that often in bullet
but instructive to knowe he didn't trade
because the white King was more
active
yeah well when two heavy weights meet
sometimes there's a lot of footwork
before you see any real punches landed
and that game was an example of that
just some footwork both guys kind of
being like all right
I'm where I want to be in the Grand
Final versus you know objectively maybe
the best opponent I could be facing I
think they both feel that way and uh a
draw starts things off and now we get a
bonon structure from Black's point of
view but the Knight comes into D4 and
mikar quickly what queen B6 by Knight F5
a
sacrifice yeah it's it's it's a bit of a
bluff according to the computer but it
doesn't matter because in bullet can you
calculate everything Hikaru laughs in
the face of danger at the night and
takes E4
carted but wow there's no mate against
this King It Feels So
open yeah magnus's attack is Raging
on car way down on the clock here by the
way yeah good call so what's happening
here black has two minor
pieces every piece is hanging and
apparently that's no good cuz Queen F6
at the end I
think he finds F6 the queen is under
Under Fire yeah so now this Queen's
under attack and the rook in the corner
a White's King is safer between the two
but black is up a full
piece dude these guys ability to just
stare down the barrel of of insanity is
is what separates them right I mean I
said coldhearted really it's cold
blooded hikaru's ability to navigate
those tactics and and Parry that those
threats Robert good try by Magnus
though but this queen on C1 covers the
G5 Square which is very important right
there the queen would have went up to G5
with a Perpetual instead the queen on C1
covers the king escapes hiar Nakamura
should take this
game yeah he's finding a way to get
surgical against that white king but
Magnus holding on is there a Perpetual
now and Hikari needs to be careful
because if Magnus was Queen C6 check he
can't pre move he would lose his Queen
that's a draw by repetition yeah is it
ah Magnus Karu shakes head couldn't find
a way out of the checks Magnus snatches
a draw from the jaws of defeat
there wow yeah hiar is probably a bit
unhappy about that he was up major
material uh but Magnus he's showing off
the mouse speed now he is improving I
think the more games he plays the faster
he gets in crunch
time yeah he's he's uh keeping up the
speed that's been the one thing you
wonder if he was going to be able to do
he did it with da did it with Ali Resa
will he maintain speed against Hikaru
this game this game he's down 5 seconds
and Hikaru
also looking pretty good he just win the
exchange for free I think he did that's
uh that's that's easy money he's up a
pawn right now and he's pushing his
pawns this is a knight and Bishop as
this just doesn't look good for black
but if anyone can weasel their way out
it feels like Magnus he's good at these
end
games B3 and C4 yeah sorry it wasn't an
exchange it was a pawn I was was
hallucinating there but ultimately white
is still just much better uh and the
fact that hikaro was also up what is
that 14 seconds on the
clock bit of a in fact Magnus just
resigns and just like that we have our
first decisive game of the match AAR
Nakamura with a onegame lead yeah Magnus
says I cannot look at that position
anymore you outplayed me good work and
now it's back to the drawing board and
the openings I feel like we haven't seen
anything of note thus far they're
they're dabbling in different lines but
you know sometimes we know we're going
to get a Berlin match or we're going to
see one side out prep the other it's
just a bunch of jockeying right now
agree but I will say the one thing we
also haven't seen is sometimes Hikaru
will play the the I'll call them the
dubious Hikaru specials right where
he'll play the B3 stuff or play the
openings he knows objectively aren't
great um because he's so comfortable
with them and he knows he can he can
outplay people anyway I don't think he's
messing around with kind of dubious
openings against Magnus Robert I think
that's one thing we've seen and although
that was a mistake for apparently it was
almost winning for him and now suddenly
black is the side for Choice black has
the bishop hair and isn't losing
material please take me says Magnus I
want to hit both your Rooks and car says
absolutely
not sh how do you play chess like that
with no time I
just I don't
know yeah I'm Magnus for like the fifth
time today is sacrific an exchange in a
great way like look at this position he
has a bishop and two pawns for a rook he
also has the healthier King his Connect
Four I win well I I'll say the other
thing he has is an edge on the clock for
the first time although right as we say
that he blunders there there some sort
of mate it's mate G5 is coming and it's
mate hiard has the sack and then this
Pawn should go just push the F Pawn
E5 oh but then there's yeah he gets
behind the pawn first and then he cut
chases it down that was well played good
technique five extra seconds on the
clock for Magnus yeah hikaro takes one
of the pawns but it's not enough
Freddy's going to get frisky on the the
f file and uh and Magnus is going to
level things up in this game unless
something wild happens he also has a
huge Edge on the clock which I think was
maybe the biggest turnaround of all
Robert in this game Magnus was leading
on the clock wire to wire and did you
see that Magnus went King E3 he gave up
his Pawn so was objectively a bad move
but he's playing faster and darar
expected the pawn to push so he Premed
his Rook up and that's why Magnus was
able to steal that rook in the game so
it's two to2 and that means we are Level
once more just like at the start and
look again they're playing a quiet line
almost as if they're playing each other
in a classical
match yeah agreed this is highle opening
chess quiet lines and uh you know
there's 40 now just under 40 minutes on
the clock so we got a lot of Chess here
we've got 55,000 of you tuning in across
all platforms don't go anywhere the fun
has just begun on this Friday I don't
know if we're going to get overtime
chess but we're going to get a an epic
Clash no matter what well he car is
going to get a pawn up Advantage cuz he
just stole one of those double eyesight
Pawns in the center but White's Pawn
structure not healthy but who cares how
healthy it is when you're up two of them
yeah couple of doubled but past e pawns
feels good hicaro rebounding here from
that loss he just had if he can if he oh
and that yeah and by the way again look
at the edge of the clock this has been
an interesting match so far Robert it
feels like the decisive games at least I
know we had a couple draws the decisive
games have been very one-sided right
like one one player is not just winning
on the board they're dominating on the
clock and the other guy has to go back
to the drawing board Magnus just
resigns yeah you're right 100% right and
also they're switching off who has the
lead on the clock in some earlier
matches one player always Jets out to a
huge time advantage and then the other
player catches up here they''re trading
off victories they're trading off time
advantages and they're also switching up
their openings and Magnus he did play
this style in the game that he won two
AO and hikaro says if you're going to go
for this again I'm ready and I'm
stealing a pawn in the center
yeah agreed by the way that that vote I
had earlier there were 5,000 votes from
the YouTube chat which which was 52%
hikaro Nakamura but then we have several
thousand from twitch and it's 58% Hikaru
Nakamura so interesting both twitch and
YouTube slightly favoring hikaro in this
match and hikaro again to be favored in
this position yeah because Rook D5 was
such a superb move there by Hikaru and
Magnus he's only down one pawn and he's
traded off Queens side pawns if he can
trade off the remaining Queens side
pawns he has a draw but aaru he's too
smart to do that he brings his King in
and that should be that when his King
and Rook pressure the C2
B yeah although Magnus still making it
tricky this is this was
awkward this is awkward I okay can you
just take G2 no cuz C4 Che would have
won The Rook that's right wow what a
weird turnar around there Here Comes
Magnus with a c PA and the clock is even
which means that mistakes might happen
but the B Pawn they're both queening but
you win win the house for for black Year
and that means that Hikaru has the upper
hand and I think we'll see our first
two-point
margin yeah hikaro nods that was hararo
Nakamura number three That's The
Confident nod followed by the duck lips
clip it and ship it everybody the first
hiar Nakamura facial expression we can
easily catalog like
this he likes it he likes it oh Danny I
miss commentating with you so I'm glad
we got the hikaro facial reader with us
today but Hikaru is a beast I think no
matter what his face tells us his play
tells us that he is just desperate to
win this event not because he's not the
better player but just because he really
wants this title uh oh yep and something
happened there there was a
blunder was Knight F4 check possible for
Magnus I think first before he brought
the queen okay ah Knight F4 and then
Queen in you win you win the KN with
check okay Magnus Magnus misplays that
you can't miss opportunities like like
that against Hikaru as we said he's the
king when it comes to this format and
you don't get many chances to swing at
him so Magnus missed an opportunity
there we're of course lucky because we
have the eal bar I mean again no no
shame in in saying that that's the truth
but uh but yeah if this one ends in a
draw hikaro maintains his two- game lead
and it's very even but hikaro is up a
few seconds so uh black is more active
pieces but hiar has more time with white
and this bishop now is terrible it's
locked in here that might have been a
bad decision but the Knight also is
stuck both can't move yeah what is going
on with this position you've got okay I
think aaro just settles on the oh okay
yeah that's literally a draw offer as
well um that was funny it was mutable
trage mut tra takes me back to H CaRu on
IC beating the Bots he would get
positions just like this close it down
and then flag the Bots but here Magnus
was repeating enough times we see some
little smile there and a draw is a fair
result but a good one for Hikaru keeps
his lead y it's funny because I think a
lot of people just don't appreciate some
of these skills Hikaru has were were
these aren't accidental these were these
were trained we always joke hearo was
raised on IC right and he was a human
who was beating Bots when Bots were
first entering the online chess servers
and and he he he figured out strategies
to beat computers which is is really
mind-blowing when you think about it and
um that's one of the reasons he is so
resourceful so pesky and and on on on
the online formats and this position I
have to say at first glance it looks
really good for white the black king
feels less safe than the white king and
the bishop is out but the king slid to
the corner and now the black king is
being
hunted yeah Magnus wants a victory he
needs to turn it around bring it back
within a
game looks like he's on Pace aaro gives
the head
shake not over yet but mag should get
this one Black's King is wide open you
just got to figure out a way to break
through if you're Magnus yeah Queen D5
Queen D7 looks like a good way to do
just that and oh can you take it he does
and bring the queen
in I think white can bring the queen to
F7 and then push this
Pawn Yeah they car trying to make things
oh you got Queen G1 C1 Queen outside
chance of
Perpetual oh the
queen take it he take the second time he
sees it the second
time that's pretty funny oh gosh you
know he he waves his hand was it doing
by the way Hikaru streaming of course
you saw that delayed reaction that was
pretty
funny didn't see the
queen and it's a one-point match once
again Danny and Hikaru going to again
one of these quiet position so these two
have been engaging in combat in the end
game
yeah botz Gambit declined I love that
git declined the rare the very rarely
cited botes gam but declined there um
but okay if Magnus wins this one Robert
then we will be level with 30 minutes
like a regular match right remember we
had 45 minutes to start this this final
uh so we get extra chess between these
two guys which is great but if Magnus
wins it basically is a wash and we're
back to 30 minutes with the tide match
what is happening the eval bar is doing
push-up over there going up and down and
it seems like there's an incredible
amount of tension what is yeah how does
this survive for hcard the king's
getting checked but there's there's no
rookie three I'm like looks like piece
okay rookie three comes he takes the
rook and it's AAR who's on the prow
mhm wow and the H Pawn is running Harry
for the
win and by the way a flex on the clock
in this game by Hikaru look at that that
is a massive time Advantage for bullet
and Bishop E4 was a great move there by
Hikaru he knew to trade pieces off
because the ensuing end game would be so
nice for him he gets that win and I
think Magnus was blinded both by the
sunlight and by H car's great moves yeah
Magnus needs to get a little help with
the curtains and uh get a little help on
the board right now with AAR Nakamura
taking a two- game lead as we reach the
30-minute Mark and uh he's on form I
guess he's answering the question that
he isn't Rusty despite having watched
Magnus for the last two hours he's ready
to now play Magnus and did you make an
unintentional Greg shahadi ICC reference
by talking about curtains if you want to
throw back to ICC usernames we can do
some trivia which is fun shout out to
Hawkeye we miss we miss we miss that guy
um but uh yeah anyway
curtains uh this looks pretty nice for
black there's a great light score Bishop
for one side and a not so great light
Square Bishop for the other and the
black king is also more
active yeah black king finds the nice E5
Square even though yeah he goes for the
bishop
ending not a position that white should
be able to win especially when you're
the one down 6 seconds on the clock so
Hikaru
continuing to do what he does in
bullet lot of time left though we got
tons of
time oh he's trying to trick him I was
like how could you give this access
point but there's Bishop A2 check and6
would have been
lost these guys are full of Tricks silly
rabbits tricks are for kids although not
in bullet
chess are for everyone in bullet this
bishop is on the best possible Square
it's keeping the king out of both
directions but that smart by hikaro he
trades some pawns the 50 move rule
starts once again and unless Magnus can
take both these pawns he's going to lose
this game on the clock yeah Karo flexing
the time the time what you got to do
yeah I wonder how good these guys are in
bullet compared to my accuracy score and
classical chess if I had to guess
they're better at bullet than I am at
classical chess just saying like this is
insane and look at Magnus so what hiar
is gonna do is put his Bishop on the I
think on G6 at some point and yeah he's
gonna take the bishop and then Magus he
did
it and the pre move for the win just as
long as you don't accidentally stalemate
or repeat a position three times Magnus
shakes his head knows that h
got the better of the the The Meta
bullet game there and that's the third
time that Hikaru has done that he beat
Aliva FIA twice in that same exact end
game with bishop and wrong corner for
The Rook pawn and now Hikaru has built
his lead up and in addition to his
three-point lead he's got a really nice
position in this game with the
uncompromised pawn structure on the king
side for white and Black's King side in
shambles yeah and now you see the
difference in body language hikaro with
the head Bob feeling that ABBA Dancing
Queen only okay that's what he's
listening to by the way um hiar just on
the prowl right now dude look at this
yeah whites up a piece up a piece up a
piece about to go up four games in the
match up four seconds on the clock
Magnus no longer bobbing his head to T
Swift someone needs to change the
momentum for Mr Carlson the only good
news that I can think of for Magnus is
he lost six games in a row against Ali
Raza and he still won the match Hikaru
is next level right that is the final
boss but he has lost series of games
then was able to go on winning streak of
his own so that at least should give him
some confidence in the back of his mind
yeah agreed that's the point we were
making at the start of the match is that
because Magnus was down against Ali Resa
and came back that has to pay dividends
here at least from a psychological
perspective if if you're if you didn't
see that match Magnus was down three
games Robert with five minutes to
go like yes he was winning the game to
make it too but that was that was
impressive and he ended up really
turning around so Magnus is not going to
go quietly into the night here no of
course not he always is a fighter and
now we're getting into an end game and
hikaru's actually been outplaying Magnus
in many of these end games he's aided by
the clock he has a slight lead in this
game as well but look at the pieace
placement he goes for
C5 yep andaru is just feeling it he's
really flexing it right now enjoying the
tune I don't know maybe that's maybe
that isn't Aba cuz that doesn't look
like a dancing queen
bee no it looks uh H I wonder what he's
listening to I was going to just throw
out a random musician but I I will ask
him when it's done he's probably not
listen to anything just the the beat of
his mov again the creepy thing would be
that he's not listening to any music oh
my God and Magnus blunders a piece Haru
maybe gonna take another
one and you know we we asked the
question would hikaro be rusty because
Magnus is the one who played two matches
Robert but the other flip side was Will
magnus's momentum turn into exhaustion
and if this one gets away from him I
think I think at this point it just
might be that uh kind of ran out of
steam here against the final boss as you
said just unreal play thus far from
mcaro he's fast he's playing very
accurately and he's getting to the end
games where he can play for two results
as we say in classical chess he knows
that if Magnus plays Super quickly he
might hold a draw but otherwise hikaro
can use the clock as the main weapon
according to one of our mods Magnus
hikaro was listening to some bwood hits
by the way if you haven't seen
rrr fantastic film sorry back to the
chest don't apologize I just watched it
the other
night you know everyone wants to be beam
out
there that was any okay we we can't turn
this into a movie podcast all right so
staying on the chest here Hikaru Harries
was a lot of pressure but Magnus still
has an edge with the bishop PA so also
the biggest note is that he's not that
down on the clock right it's very close
I think that's huge for Magnus to keep
the speed
up yeah and look at this end game it is
even material two Bishops against Bishop
Knight pair and Magnus should be better
but I'm not sure he trusts himself that
he might even look at this position one
that in the back of his head he wants to
win but at the same time he's like I
don't want to lose on
time
yeah you don't want to lose on time but
uh you also don't want to lose on the
board at this point I don't think Magnus
is in danger of losing on the board but
can he create enough for a win you got
to start racking up some dubs here down
by five and the pawns trading off is
really good news for the night right the
Knight is a slow moving piece the
Bishops they look across the board in a
better way E5 is dropping but then A3
would be captured so mag is desperately
Clinging On to both of his pawns yeah
he's trying to create some sort of
Swindle he does manage to steal one but
Hikaru wait okay there's some chances to
win here and time is even enough that
Magnus could convert this no I think
what Magnus could have done was take
this Pawn he could to Bishop E6 and took
it I'm worried him getting flagged and
he takes the pawn right now yeah yeah
okay there you go there you go a draw
apparently aaru has crossed lines that
very few should Venture into he's
listening to niichel whoa look at this
Photograph Danny every time I do it
makes me
laugh although I will say why does nicob
back get so much hate what is the deal
with niichel back getting all the hate I
don't know but all the answer that we
all want is like what was on Joey's head
can can we just get
that what the hell was on Joey's
[Laughter]
head this is where I grew up you know
the I grew up watching these two in some
ways online not really I'm an old man
but uh
that's how I there are some people
growing up watching these guys it's true
and uh as we get back to the chest white
is up a pawn so Magnus needs to show
that Magnus technique and he brings his
King all the way up but he's dropping
pawns and I'm worried about him losing
another
game yeah the Knight is just so pesky
there the king is in a in a in a danger
zone for sure there are mating that
possibilities although look at the
aggression I like this F5 if we're
traded Into The Rook
ending
well car's fine sorry yeah he does well
car's actually doing fine I mean Magus
needs to be reminded of who he really is
you know he's going to the end game he
needs he needs to be reminded of who he
really is um can you take on I think
Karo can just take on D7 and he doesn't
realize it yeah take on D7 and King d8
and it's over now he stops to calculate
I think he's not wait what happened yeah
no no he realized that he was winning
cuz he's on a delay because he's
streaming so he's like I could have just
captured his rook and won the end game
oh it was perpet okay I didn't realize
that they that it was a draw yeah but he
just realized he was winning if he had
traded
Rooks oh this looks really bad for
hikaro though like I know hikaro
sometimes plays some dodgy stuff but
handing your opponent the light squares
in front of your king feels like a bad
idea
usually
is he uh he couldn't make it as a wise
man maybe he'll make it as a poor man
stealing although right now Magnus is
going to steal
one Danny that that game reminds us of
who Magnus Carlson is this is how you
remind us Magnus of who you really
are yeah I don't know if I want to keep
going in this Nick I can like I can if
you want um we can force it all day this
is we should I wonder if one day we'll
confess how many times you and I have
played the game where we were sneaking
words on the show because our producers
don't want to know that but every once
in a while Talent has to uh you know we
won't go there but every once in a while
we have fun I mean Danny come on let's
be real someday somehow I'm gonna make
it all right but not right
now okay well Magus to make it all right
right now because he's down a lot in the
match but he's better in this position
because he's going right after hiar is
King yeah he is although he still down
five games though I feel like he just
won didn't that make it four maybe I
missed something um well I think we
missed a lot because we were seeing we
were you know stuck in in Nickelback
references which is uh you know never go
full Nickelback as they
say I agree with that chat that hikaro
is so good he's been playing Amazing
chess but in this game look at hikaru's
King it's wide open and Magnus isn't
even down any material for this attack
yeah Magnus is rolling here and it is a
four game it is a four game I'm glad
that even when I lose my focus pull
nickel back I was I was uh on top of the
score there Magnus should bring this to
three games unless something crazy
happens although I'm not going to doubt
those Knights this is this is this is
uh okay he's doing a good job cleaning
up the tactics no more Forks push him
baby and uh Magnus brings us he's slow
no no Magnus is slow right now he's down
to 6 seconds he should get this done but
he's playing very
slowly yeah Hikaru was pre-moving the
bleep out of this okay but that was good
that was really nice by Magnus there to
push his F Pawn get his King involved
and not fall for a fork so Magnus it's
back to three points he's feeling better
you can see it on his face but Hikaru
still has a healthy lead in the
match 18 minutes to go remember we had
45 minutes to start which ultimately is
huge for Magnus because at this point if
it was 30 minutes probably would be down
and out right so this is um this is
exactly what we what we uh wanted to see
the most chess possible between these
two guys in a final and uh Magnus is uh
turning the momentum around yeah I mean
Magnus is asking could you say goodbye
to yesterday because If Today Was Your
Last Day you got to win this
Bu you're you are Shameless you're
Shameless
oh well back to the uh to the bullet
here it looks like Magnus with the black
pieces he's much better because his King
is safer and he's going after hikaru's
pawns yeah and if A2 Falls this is one
of those positions that it's it's it's
hard to lose as black that's the other
problem is that Magnus is up on the
clock and there aren't any tricks right
sometimes you're losing but there you
know there's weirdness to come there's
night Forks there's King safety in this
position the uh the game is a pretty
easy one for black to play yeah you're
up a pawn and a clear extra he goes
Bishop C he wants the outermost Pawn
bring the king over to E8 and play
Bishop d8 I think that's what oh he gave
up the a pawn for the D Pawn but that
was a surprising decision
yeah yeah I don't know that that
improves his winning chances so right as
I say that maybe Hikaru was in a
position to hold this that would be
unfortunate for Magnus for his momentum
to come to a screeching halt and by the
way Hikaru up enough on the clock that
that this could get dangerous yes it
really could and now you see both
players scrambling at the moment and
look at that defense from M he plants
his Bishop in front of the pawn and now
he's the one with the active king and a
passer of his own
yep gosh what is going on there Queen
ending invited seven seconds for Magnus
10 for
Hikaru and Magnus wants to trade Queens
but not at that point no he didn't want
to trade Queens right there oh wait but
white was winning if you took because
some weird opposition yeah know the king
the white King was you took on D6 and
King C8 White was winning
yeah dude that's crazy though that's two
end games hikaro has missed the chance
to trade into a winning King and pawn
ending and again we don't have time you
know this is not the most instructive
CHF show you're ever going to watch on
Twitch everyone uh because it's bullet
but yeah white was winning due to
irregular flanking opposition there and
uh crazy stuff yeah that was pretty wild
and it's hard to trade like that because
your king is so far away you think I
might lose the game and that is
definitely not something that a car
wants and you know what he's doing he is
waiting he's going to go down to one
second left and then make bishop H6 it
will be a three time repetition the game
will be a draw but at least he burns 30
more seconds off the match
clock yeah and he's pausing to make sure
he does that um and playing the metag
game taking a sip of that giant mug of
water there's not really much to do here
looking at this analysis every time I do
it makes me laugh every time I do it
makes
me
I can't do it anymore D I'm trying to
wean off the Nickelback references
because otherwise I'm going to burn it
to the
ground sorry I was slow on the update
there reading chat and that laugh was
probably a little unnecessary I'm so
glad it's a weekend
um all right well the draw the draw
comes to AAR Nakamura he has a 10 to
seven lead we'll uh we'll switch that
scoreboard here in just a second but
yeah that draw Burns some time off the
clock and um and hikaro Nakamura
maintaining his lead yeah he he's really
playing a great match but Magnus is
making it more and more competitive not
just by the scoreboard but just the way
Magnus has played in many of these games
but I like what hikaro is doing here
look at how even this position is and
it's a complete draw and that allows
hikaro to burn even more time off the
clock because he's he's not going to
lose this game
and Magnus if he doesn't play quickly at
some point Nar may say I'm not making a
draw anymore I'm going to try to flag
you yeah but I'm just furious right now
with our mods who did a poll for the
best Nickelback song where's photograph
oh photograph's at the top green because
I missed it yeah photograph there you go
photograph is is probably their best
song yeah of course it
is yeah another another king and Pa
ending hikaro going to get as much time
off the clock as he can although I will
say this at this point the meta of
getting time off the clock isn't that
relevant yet right this is not the type
of lead Robert that is devastating it's
a three-game lead remember if it even
gets within one game we have overtime
chess because the new rules are that you
have to win bullet matches by two so I'm
just pointing out that regardless of the
fact that we're losing time here I I
don't think that he's in a position to
really protect the lead like that yet
yeah it takes me back to hikaro versus
Wesley so and those speeches
championships where they did this
forever it felt like cuz there was
increment which made it worse because
you could make a little pawn move at
some point and then start over again uh
in pure bullet with Z seconds added per
move yeah someone's going to uh flag
they can't just wait forever so the 50
move rule happened and now we see in
this game Magnus he's going for it he is
on the offensive on the king side but
has he
overextended a nice strike by hikaro to
play F5 that's actually a really
thematic instructive point I know we
said we don't get a lot of analysis and
bullet everybody but that was a really
great thing because white has also
opened his King with this Pawn storm and
that's what black points out with this
F5 move so Hikaru makes it spicy and
both kings are in danger and what's
going on here the queen went up to C4
black blocked it is there trouble on
this E6 square if you can tra he just
dropped the pawn on
E6 wa didn't didn't Magnus have there
was a knight on E6 he could have taken
this Pawn on D6 so Magnus with the
oversight and now Hikaru I mean he looks
like he's getting a knight F3 in
there
yeah wow hiar turned that around
consider it done as far as Nickelback
Nickelback references in an interview
consider a dunk maybe we'll do that
thing all of us are in the inside joke
oh who King F2 Knight takes
E2 yeah that look at the time Hikari was
kind of burning some of the clock and
then he made that move and it was a
rough decision and Magnus when Bishop G5
allowing this he had better options but
he just wants to make a draw he does not
want to lose on time he just wants to
grab these
pawns yeah he's only got six seconds if
picaro keeps a pawn he has winning
chances but Magnus will have none of it
that one got away from Hikaru and again
I know we've seen hikaro doing more of
the meta bullet things here milking the
clock protecting a lead but with 11
minutes plus to go here you know we
already saw Magnus overcome a three-game
deficit in five minutes versus Al Resa
fuja so this is this is close I'm
totally with you I think that Hikaru
he's trying to use that strategy to his
advance Advantage but in some of these
games it's his disadvantage you'd rather
win a game in 20 seconds than draw a
game in a minute there's still enough
time for Magnus to make this comeback
and look at this position it's very
sharp where white has an extra Pawn or
did have an extra Pawn over there on the
queen side now black is in the driver
seat D5 is that's a weakness and whoa
that was a quick spot by Magnus yeah
yeah yeah and he's going to have a
couple extra pawns here plus the bishop
versus knight dynamic should be better
for black only thing you have to watch
out for usually is the time against aaro
but Magnus also up 5 seconds on the
clock here so a good turnaround for
Carlson uh oh but that open King Hikaru
is not going to make this easy spying
some tactic and3 just fell and now it
looks like we're into an end game that
unfortunately for Magnus should be a
draw but now I'm looking at the clock
Magnus is the one up a few seconds he's
also up a pawn he should try to win this
game he should and now he's got a pass E
Pawn this is a lot harder to hold than
it looks for white if Magnus can uh can
keep his cool on the clock he is still
up three seconds that's
huge yeah this is not easy King could go
to F5 oh also E3 this is objectively now
it's objectively losing for white Magnus
in position to bring this back to two
games oh but hiar tricked him hikaro
tricked him when the Rook in front the
king could come back to the second rank
but if the The Rook wasn't back there
there was going to be an E1 check and
now hiar up on time oh my goodness and
he's the one who could
win on the board I mean okay it's going
to be a draw but I wonder if he
shouldn't have traded Rooks there that's
crazy wow wow what a save that was
incredible he understood that if his
Rook was behind the pawn which you
normally want he couldn't get his King
back so he drops The Rook to the first
rank brings it in front of the pawn and
his King was able to Scamper back just
in the Nickelback of time so that was a
nice save there by Hikaru Nakamura and
and now we have another game that's
Mainline
stuff uh and yeah we're going to do the
game chat where all of us are on this
inside joke and Robert and I are going
to try to squeeze Nickelback references
into the interview and it'll be awesome
it's going to be fun um I don't know who
we're going to be interviewing we still
got a long ways to go
I will say that I again I know it's a
three-game lead but hikaru's had his
chances Robert objectively I think to
make the lead bigger we we know he
missed those spots in a couple of end
games right where he didn't convert to
the king ofon ending so will it come
back to haunt him right now Magnus again
threatening to make it a two- game lead
he's should be winning this I don't see
how you stop this Pawn unless you give
up your rook and A7 right now who cares
about this bishop you are getting this
queen Magnus he wins a quick game there
it's only a two point that's huge that's
huge exactly no this is uh again I think
that I it's it's too early to provide
criticism overall in any sort of match
strategy but I do think Hikaru protected
his lead a little bit with a couple of
those draws and Magnus saved Magnus held
on and now might have a little bit of
momentum as we head into the final
minutes and now we have another
complicated opening where black is
attacking on the queen side and also
White's not attacking anywhere because
the Rook on C8 keeps wh pieces
honest yeah we2 was a nice little trick
he goes and steals that one whoa But
Here Comes Carlson on the second
rank is there takes an F4 so he missed
something better I don't know what it
was but it clear the eval bar instead of
being all the way down for black it went
back towards the middle and somehow hiar
is
escaping how
yeah I don't know how hikaro escaped
that that and now now it's turning
around the other way 93 he blundered the
endgame hiar has got an extra Pawn on
the outside oh this is just great for
AAR in fact he's winning I think if I'm
Magnus I might just
resign
wow oh and as soon as I say that hikaro
blunders the pawn hiar blunders right
back what's the time 28 to 18 seconds so
hikaro should oh F6 check he pre-m moved
it hikaro played King E5 and Magnus had
pre moved F6 the house Falls with the E6
pawn and what a huge win for Hikaru that
is to keep magnus's momentum back and
you could just see the pain in magnus's
face as they get into another end game
no Queens on the board in this one uh it
seems to be the match strategy for these
Players let's go down to the end game
white has the bishop pair but we'll see
if Magnus is still reeling from that
loss he needed to hold that game but he
still does have enough time to get a
couple wins
here
what is this position Denny this just
looks really good for Magnus to my eyes
and the Evo bar is absolutely
unfaced
yeah looks great for white but it's also
a closed position that could go for a
while here the def file being the only
open one so it's I'm I'm starting to
play the metag game Robert I'm looking
at the time again Magnus did overcome
three games in five minutes versus
peruja but Nakamura is a different
animal and uh you're starting to get up
against it where the closed positions
are are ones you just have to avoid even
if you're
better now black is better and he pushes
his Pawn so maybe some trades will
happen opposite color Bishops there's a
check on D5 here sorry why is black
better because the B Pawn is just that
strong you're asking me you
know eal Bar Needs a raise now that is a
pun I could get behind right there um
okay Magnus finds a way to get the
counterplay unfortunately though it it
this is a draw that's going to take
another 30 seconds off the total game
clock for sure hikaro is goingon to milk
this all the way to the end and we're
going to be under five minutes and if
you're hikaro I don't think you push the
B Pawn you might just lose that end game
as black will be up a piece but white
will have these pass pawns that will
roll up the board so Magnus needs to go
like King G5 back to F5 back and forth
over there and hikaro might yeah he goes
in he goes in for the win he go he goes
for
it the car's down down time he's losing
oh
F4 and here push it too far Magnus just
needs to move it doesn't matter if you
blunder a huge momentum shift here F6
and E7 oh my
gosh what a momentum
shift Magnus Carlson wins to bring this
within two games and we have 4 minutes
and 45 seconds left I spoke too soon I
thought I thought it was a dead obstacle
Bishop ending hikaro should have taken
the draw mhm and then hiar brought his
King in he could have repeated at any
moment and you saw the Grimace on his
face that was one of those I shouldn't
have done that why did I do it and
speaking of why is he doing things what
is this opening for white it looks
really
bad yeah this is where hikaro is you got
to take a breath and not go into the the
kind of dubious opening Lane that again
sometimes he can revert to which works
against 99 99% of people in bullet but
Magnus is going to get positions like
this and be better if Hikaru plays those
weird openings just light Square
domination you can't kick that yeah whoa
a queen sack on
G4 wow wow he made that decision so
quickly looks pretty good yeah that that
was that was ridiculous that might be
one of the most ridiculous moments of
the
match he's losing the game though yeah
he he's losing the game now it's falling
apart and that King is in a lot of
danger what a move there G5 by the way
forcing The Rook to the awkward square
and this is going to be a one- game
match with three minutes to go everybody
buckle up you're looking at a couple of
rockars where the chess comes easy and
the blunders are
cheap Danny I thought you were saving me
from all the Nickelback references and
then go well what wait wait wondered and
and it seems like Magnus could have
taken more advantage of it but didn't
but still he has the better position and
the safer King a knight into D5 the
bishop slicing across the board a
longrange piece against the black
king yeah the momentum again we've seen
it happen Magnus overcame momentum
against fua very similar to this down
three games with about five minutes left
now he's only down by one and uh you got
to win by two thanks for everything you
just said Captain Obvious you're welcome
I do appreciate but you know what I
would do if I'm hiar here I'm looking at
the overall match clock but it's only a
onepoint spread look to flag Magnus
Bishops are more difficult to move than
Rooks in time scrambles mag is doing the
right thing pushing his Pawn all over
the board it's a bishop and three pawns
for a rook and yet here I am saying look
at the clock and look at aaro's
chances yeah yeah objectively the chess
is good for white here but the Rook is
so much easier to play in these spots
the bishop is stuck you can't pre-move
like look at this The Rook can already
pre in a way that white cannot and
that's such a practical advantage in
these games he's going he's going for
the he goes for it but he had to take
time on it yeah he's moving very slowly
and Hikaru playing oh a repetition I
don't think that's good for Hikaru I
felt like he could have played on yeah
yeah I think he should have played King
E5 there instead of the last Rook A5 and
allowed the game to go on now now you're
down to a game though that that could be
it right if Hikaru wins this
game that's it
Magnus got to win to send us into
overtime or at least not lose and what
is this opening it looks very
adventurous and White's King is safely
castled Black's King remains in the
center but black does have the pair of
Bishops so I would say initial Advantage
white but if the checkman attack doesn't
happen quickly then black suddenly might
be right back in
this agreed F6 a spicy
move and you want that Knight on D5 but
he wants more than just a
trade wow Rook enters the center But
Here Comes Bishop E3 but Rook D3 oh he
walked into it check I missed the check
oh you had a check I missed a check oh
everybody missed the check I mean we're
in scary territory this queen just
wrapped around a B5 but it's doing
nothing over there in fact the E4 Pawn's
about to drop and the F6 Pawn is also
weak in the end game no one knows what's
going on here least of all the eval bar
it's a 5-second Time Advantage though
for Hikaru which is huge huge if things
stay the same Magnus has got to make
something happen or he's going to get
flagged yes though if Magnus is going to
lose he better keep an eye on the match
clock and then resign immediately
because there's still time left and he
would have a chance to win that game but
uh oh it's getting bad for him it looks
like the Evo bar saying white is better
that's a brilliant point if Magnus is
going to lose he needs to resign like
like now yes but it's unclear you know
in this position looks like black is the
one who's doing well he's stealing the
pawns but his clock is down under 11
seconds he's grabbing all the pawns he's
got to go has to rush this like he's
never rushed before yep 10 seconds here
comes the
a it's a tide match it's a tide match
and they get one more game I think I
think there were seconds on the clock so
this game doesn't start the six move um
mini match that they would have to see
who can win by two uh we'll get word
from our producers but he went Rook B4
I'm not sure if he was going for a
cheeky you know my opponent might pre
moove or he mous it but either way
Magnus takes the game and we are noted
up at 13
and2 om jeser snaps there's a reason
those emotes exists for subscribers
emotes like this because we freak out
when bullet chess happens and this is uh
this is crazy and Hikaru again just felt
like he he snatched a defeat snatched a
draw there from the from the jaws of
Victory he he and Magnus has got to get
credit for keeping in those games by the
way Magnus now up on the clock here this
is a renewed sense of faith in his
ability to win this match and while we
are seeing some trades the H4 Pawn is
loose that Bishop on G7 hitting the E5
Pawn but I think Magnus with the lead on
the clock and I would take his position
even though that Rook just landed in the
enemy
camp completely agreed you got to like
White's position here this is this is
regulation we have had it confirmed We
Believe by production and game Ops who
are behind the scenes making sure well
what was rookie four he's going for a
rook lift I guess there was a knight F6
check and opening up the E file there's
something here apparently there is he
goes Queen D3 He wants Rook d8 with a
mating attack the queen blocks on G6
yeah yeah there was Queen takes F3 there
for Black by the way everyone that's why
he retreated to D3 Hikaru trying to get
the Queens off the board who's better
here with the a pawn the E I have no
idea what's going on will Magnus just
settle on a draw I think he does and you
see Magnus he's mad at himself because
he was up about 7 seconds the match
remains tied now we are into overtime
and so this it changes things it's still
win by two and they get six games so
after the sixth game if there's someone
in the lead they win the match even if
it's just a one-point margin Denny this
is what the people
wanted this is what the people wanted
it's what they signed up for I am uh I
am just sitting here like a little kid
just bundled up on Christmas opening
presents knows that all of them are
going to be great doesn't matter I don't
even know what's going on or any other
holiday I'm excited hey you like to open
presents I think Magus wants to open the
C file this Rook would have caused some
problems but he doesn't do that instead
he gives himself the four square and
goes to the B file and watch out the A2
Pawn is hang Rook B two oh my God that's
nasty if you take it we're going to have
a baby girl Britney on B1 you can't give
black oh my God it's all falling apart
here
Hikaru will be down in the match by the
way for the first time today if he loses
Hikaru has not trailed in this match
wait where did Magus Queen just go he
didn't Retreat it he could have brought
it back to F7 but he goes for this and
maybe we spoke too
soon what just
happened oh my gosh this F6 Pawn is
hanging
did how did that
happen and he pre moved King h8 and he's
just losing in the
game
wow well I gave a commentator's curse
earlier and it backfired on hikaro
Nakamura I guess I just cursed Magnus
there because I am shocked that hikaro
Nakamura has won that
game I just can't believe Magus didn't
drop his Queen back when he was stealing
all the Pawns in the position maybe he
just didn't realize there was there was
a bishop on B3 before that he didn't
realize he could go back but that's a
thing of the past and right now Magnus
with the white pieces has a nice
position but he's down 5 seconds so he
needs to go after this D6 Pawn he needs
to hammer away at hikaro setup did he
just oh he got so fortunate oh my God
was loose so so lucky he blundered the
skewer but it didn't
matter iaro worse in this position but
as you said up a few seconds on the
clock but again it's win or go home
literally if anyone earns a two-point
margin everybody that's it ship it we're
done and what is happening here The Rook
B3 the steals a pawn but this open SE
file watch out for the black king oh
they're making mistakes both them of
course it's bullet it happens there's
apparently a winning queen7 free KN free
night7 it was just hanging oh he's still
hanging he sees it the third
time oh my goodness oh my gosh agreed
these games never disappoint oh my gosh
hikaro on a little bit of a delay that's
the moment where his night was
hanging and now Bishop is hanging it's
not over though oh he just dropped a
second piece so he first Knight a bishop
and his Queen's not trapped but look at
Magnus just get those Queens off the
board and then oh he didn't even have to
hiar
resigned yeah hikaro throws in the Chow
we're back to tide all netted up 15
games a piece moving on to our third
game in overtime
everybody I haven't seen in overtime
this good since Yukon Syracuse back in
that big East tournament this is really
some Epic stuff I mean they must both be
super nervous at this stage and look at
Magnus adopting this French likee
structure with a light score
Bishop yeah good for black here Magnus
increasing his space advantage on the
queen side highlevel chess and bullet
look at this move King D7 by the way oh
connecting the
Rooks this a great end game that's what
they say right I hate on the French in
the opening but when you get to the end
game it's almost always better for black
because the base Pawn F7 very hard to
get to and look at White's pawns they're
sticking out a bit yep yep opposite
position you want to be in in a French
also no Edge on the clock this time for
Hikaru he is staring down what could be
his first deficit in the match and the
last time you said it you jinxed Magnus
this time you almost did as well
apparently but look at that these
Knights they're going right after this
rook and if Rook
C2 what is happening here I have no idea
he's going to take C1 and be Down The
Exchange but he's got some
compensation oh no look a trick he wants
to trade them all he wants to trade all
is gonna take everything off the board
hikaro doesn't want it and hikaro is in
huge trouble Magnus just has to take why
did he spend like 5 seconds in that turn
he is wasting
time yeah now he's losing the C pawn and
he doesn't even win the material back
this is going the wrong direction for
hiar uh for Magnus okay but he did go up
a piece here
and keeping Knight at five go give a
check just give a check somewhere what's
the time oh but you got 10 to 7 Seconds
here and it's now under super dangerous
for Magnus yeah he's pre-moving he's
trying his best oh he's blown the A5
pawn and now a car's taking it and he's
taking the G6 PA if the Rooks come off
even better now oh my gosh and mag's
lost in
time wow he screams at the screen
unbelievable
I don't know what he's yelling about but
that is not what you wanted Hikaru
maintains a one-game lead or regains a
one game lead and Magnus has never LED
in this match and I think part of it is
your fault the commentator's curse
strikes again I'll shut up I mean no you
do the talking hey we're not rooing for
anybody every time every time Magnus
gets close to taking his first lead
again they just joining Hikaru has led
this match wire to wire Magnus completed
at one point what was it four was it
five games at one
point it ballooned up to quite a
substantial difference between them I
guess they're chatting maybe hikaro
because his matches haven't been close
he doesn't know that overtime is still
win by two ah they're checking to see
what game they are so that is very smart
that is really smart by both of them
they're seeing how many games do we have
left before it becom sudden death
yeah yeah yeah so they're chatting with
the team uh staff confirmed it was five
games
of a lead for hikaro Nakamura at one
point in fact at a couple different
points hikaro had a five-game lead so we
are in overtime chess here both players
confirming where the match
sits it's a win by two scenario unless
we get to six games and then it's sudden
death whoever wins is your bullet chess
champion although actually if Magnus
Carlson wins we get more chess so for
the content many people rooting for
Magnus for the for the hikaro they don't
want to see any more
sh and who do you think that little
stall favored because Magnus lost the
game but both players must be nervous so
do feel like any side gets the upper
hand thanks to that mini
break I think with players like this who
are just objectively so good it probably
doesn't really matter um but I you have
to believe it always favors the person
who lost the game to be able to take a
breath so maybe Magnus can kind of
control his uh his emotions for a moment
he is up he is up a little bit in in
terms of space here oh and that D6 Pawn
is the worst Pawn on the board if you
can get around your dark Square Bishop
so yeah a little bit extra space for
Magnus but a lot of extra time for
Hikaru 5 Seconds at the
moment and whoa what just happened to
the king what just happened there I look
away for a second and it's like vacuumed
off the
board yeah everything just exited hikaro
probably okay with the draw even though
that doesn't win the match cuz he's
black gives him another chance to win
with white remember it's win by two
unless we get to get to Seven to the
seventh game this is an incredibly
played game thus far Danny I've been
watching the evil bar it hasn't moved
they played all the best moves to this
point and black gives up a piece but
gets a bunch of Pawns and it's going to
be a draw by Perpetual check maybe not
but hi car should play for a win look at
the
clock he should he should and he knows
it and he does it hikaro going in wait
there was a blunder Queen B6 yeah this
part is promoting he allowed the queen
in the part you see it on mag's face he
knows it's over oh my God and
that and that is how hamura defended his
bullet CH championship title oh my
goodness that was a Clash of Titans and
aaru speaking to his fans his audience
on his stream but Magnus you know he's
is disappointed there with the second
place finished but Hikaru he didn't
Trail a single time in the match and
Magnus almost made it happen but almost
is not good
enough a wire-to-wire victory for the
reigning bullet chess champion Magnus
Carlson will not get one of the only
titles in chess that has evaded him at
this point in his career Kar Nakamura is
still the bullet chess
champion still again fourth time bullet
chess champion and look at that final
score 17 to 15 we had free chess we had
overtime and for Magnus you got to give
him credit for that comeback he was
trailing throughout the match he almost
took a lead but he couldn't just make it
work he in the time scrambles Hikaru was
simply
better wow what a thriller kind of weird
how it ended there with the players
confirming the score I I I I mean but it
all happened so fast in the end Nakamura
does what he's done most of his career
which is oute outplay out battle people
and bullet and he is still the uh the
bullet again World chess champion if you
want to call it that it's not World bday
relax but you get
it what a crazy what a crazy day we just
had and well it's been a crazy day it's
been a crazy week but it's over our
bracket will not change from here there
there are no nobody else joining the
competition nobody else left standing
besides Hikaru Nakamura so it's all over
Hikaru Nakamura is your champion and so
with that I think we are going to take a
break leave your questions in the chat
because when we return Danny and I will
be joined by none other than your bullet
chest Champion hiar
Nakamura did you teach uh certain
positions or openings or middle games or
what what did that your what did your
training uh people look like I'll give
you one of the secrets here so a good CH
a good coach will correct your moves but
a great coach will correct your thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back can you just repeat that again
so a good coach will correct your
moves and a great coach will correct
your thinking so really part of the
magic of coaching is holding a mirror up
to a child's and so they can see their
own thinking and sometimes you made the
move because you were overconfidence uh
you were dismissive of your opponent and
so these whether they were this kind of
self- knowledge this self-awareness is
part of the cognitive process and it
helps to accelerate their learning curve
as as as players um and so meaning games
are that lost because you didn't know
the Roy Lopez you didn't know the 14th
move of the Roy Lopez or because you
couldn't execute a rook impon end game
yes of course these are te these are
technical things that you need to win
chess games but games are also a loss
because of lack of self- knowledge so um
the issue of spasy losing to Pion you
know you I tell the story many times was
spasy lost the world championship to pan
in
1966 spasy goes back to Banick and he
says you know why did why did I lose now
uh people many people may not know bbasi
was an incredibly talented chess player
right in many ways he's considered one
of the first Universal chess player he
can attack like T and he can defend like
pjan but he loses this match and bck
told him uh the great talented Boris
basy uh did you study
pan right so meaning it was he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from sunzu know
your enemy know yourself in the Thousand
battles you you will never lose uh he
just thought it was about about spasy
and so he had to take the time and
recognize that he needed to understand
pan beating you means I must understand
you chess is a conversation is a
dialogue between the two chess players
so by 1969 he knew what to expect at the
chess board he has he had studied uh pan
and he eventually becomes uh the 10th uh
world
[Music]
champion
that's
[Music]
awesome and we are back just about ready
to interview your champion of the 2023
bullet chest Championship Hikaru
Nakamura as I said before the break the
bracket it's set in stone nothing will
change and the name that will be written
in the history books as the winner is
AAR
Nakamura he got the job done wow was
that a Wild Ride Robert he he holds on
at one point with a five-game lead
Magnus Carlson comes storming back wins
by two in
overtime I could say a lot more but I
think we're just going to look at the
bracket and see how we got the job done
Robert yeah the the final name does the
talking Hikaru Nakamura he talks while
playing chess at the highest level and
he's about to talk to us so Hikaru we
welcome you into the show huge
congratulations how are you feeling now
that you just took down Magnus
Carlson yeah I mean it was a crazy match
obviously at at at some points I thought
I had the match under control I mean I I
think there was this there were many
many games were back and forth but I
think pretty consistent consistently I
was the one who was ahead on the clock
and because of that I was really
pressing him Magnus found some amazing
resources there were probably two or
three games when I was up I want to say
like three or four where I thought it
was GG and um he kept hanging and there
was that one game where I was up by
three the bishop ending and then I tried
to win it like I told myself I was just
going to make the draw with the opposite
color Bishops I went for it and then it
kind of went downhill um but nonetheless
uh it was just I think really really
excited for the fans I'm I'm glad that I
found a way to keep it keep it together
at the very
end is it hard to keep your emotions
together when you know there were games
like that H car like the bishop ending
there was that one game that maybe you
could have traded Rooks and been winning
in the king and pawn ending which you
realized after and if your opponent
makes a comeback are those are those
games kind of calling at you and and
distracting you or are you able to
forget them and just stay focused in the
moment well I mean there's one very
important thing which is that uh for
better or worse I've lost a bunch of
games against Magus where he's he's
pulled the shenanigans he finds ways to
to win games that he should never win
let alone draw and so I've had a lot of
experience at being on the wrong end of
those games and um so I think having had
those experiences certainly helps a lot
in terms of uh not like not like going
over the top and losing your mind um I I
mean Magnus does it better than anyone
else like even when I think about my
games against Ali Reser other is like
they aren't able to find ways to uh to
survive losing positions when they get
the good positions they they do things
but the losing positions where they can
turn around it doesn't happen that often
and um I mean the the fact that Magnus
did that just with all the experience I
was able to just keep going I think more
more than that um the mindset that I had
um there was there was also a game where
I think I I blundered I was just getting
I was down like it queen of Rook versus
queen with the past E Pawn I think or D
Pawn whichever pawn it was um and I just
said keep going keep making moves and
that that was sort of the emblematic of
the spirit I had which which is once the
game ended you just keep moving forward
you just keep keep trying to play moves
um and I I seem to do it quite well and
I think I think that was the main thing
is I just I I really mastered the tempo
um and I was able to just keep moving
quickly and and Magnus I mean he just
wasn't able to be as precise in in some
of the critical
games well on that note Hikaru it seemed
like many of the games were taken to the
end game quite quickly some early Queen
trades was that part of your pre-match
preparation you don't you don't have no
more opponents to face you can let us
know what your prep was
yeah I mean I think that um Magnus going
into going into the end games was a huge
mistake um actually now I can say this
too I there were a couple games against
oi res as well where I felt like um when
he was ahead by maybe two or maybe it
was three games or like two or three
games with the blackfast I think where I
got these quick end games I was able to
just get into the Rhythm move really
quickly and I felt for Magnus was a huge
mistake going to the end games because I
think in general I was just quicker than
him and it's not as though Magnus can't
outplay me obviously I mean he is one of
the greatest if not the greatest endgame
players of all time but I I felt that
the end games that we were getting in
the moves were too easy for me it was a
situation where I'm trying to think of a
good analogy I guess I'll use American
football as the analogy but um you know
in in American football there are two
type they're like they're running backs
and one type of running is what we call
downhill running where basically you
just run right into the linebackers
ahead of you go straight into them the
other ones where you Juke you try to go
side to side all that other stuff and um
very much I felt like it was very
downhill where my moves were just
instant I could make the moves instant
it's like going right into the game you
don't have to think there's none of this
fancy schmancy but you go right into the
game and um I thought it was a huge
mistake for Magnus to go into the end
games um as much as he did I also
thought maggus didn't vary the openings
enough I got too many of these positions
that were similar to my match against
josam earlier because josam also plays
E4 D4 Knight F3 Bishop D3 C3 and um same
thing happened today where so many games
I got like the first 15 20 moves without
having to think and then I was just
quicker than Magnus so I I I would say
those were going to the end games and
the the lack of variety especially with
the white pieces were probably his two
mistakes but obviously it still could
have gone either way even at the end um
Magnus just he wasn't able to keep
together in those final two games and um
I mean I just just found a
way amazing stuff he Caro this is your
fourth bullet chest Championship out I
think I think you've also won a whole
lot of of speeches championships but one
thing that's been different in these
last two events is you beat Magnus
Carlson in the final and obviously we
know that the uh there's a lot going on
in the world of online chess right and
so having the opportunity to play Magnus
is that does that make these a little
bit sweeter getting getting Magnus in in
these events that you haven't beaten him
before does that make this title a
little bit more important than even the
previous one yeah I I mean I I I I don't
want a downplay because of course if I
say what everyone knows that I want to
say people are going to be mad and and
everything so I guess what I would say
in general terms is that uh you know
when I when I look at playing Magnus is
always a great great pleasure to play
against the best player in the world I
think for me um um I I feel like I can
compete with him on equal terms I think
I've proven that actually over the last
year so but more more importantly and
beyond that I think the the thing that a
lot of people don't understand and the
thing that really does separate Magnus
besides the fact that he's just a beast
and plays such great chess um is the
psychological grip that he has a
psychological Edge I mean if you looked
at his match against Oli Resa oi Reza
was so close to winning and it seemed
like he was going to win that match
Magus was able mentally to keep it
together better than Oli Resa was he was
able to win those games at the end and
and snatch that Victory away from oi
Resa I think was actually quite similar
Daniel had some good positions very
early once he missed like one or two of
those opportunities boom it just all
went downhill instantly and um so I mean
I I feel like it's a lot of it is in the
mind and I I I think I said this before
but as far as bullet goes I I think that
if I keep it together and I just like I
don't get inside my own head uh I can
play with anybody and I I think I've
I've proved that especially against the
best player in the world the last few
times yeah you certainly have proven
against any opponent that comes your way
and I guess a question I have for you is
are there any people people out there
even in this field that you see room for
improvement from them or any upand
comers that you think will be
challenging for BCC titles in the
future um I mean I I think Oli Resa
obviously is a big question mark I think
you know when I look at Oli Rea uh
whether it's bullet or Blitz or rap or
classical I mean I think there's
probably some some mental things that he
needs to work out I think if he works
those out I mean the sky really is the
limit for him um I mean Magus Magus is
Magus I I mean I don't even know how you
say Magus can improve cuz he's obviously
so ridiculously good already um but I I
think that if I was looking at any
player it probably be oi Resa maybe even
Dan if Dan could actually stop uh stop
being so afraid of Magnus and myself I I
I mean maybe I shouldn't say that but I
I do get the sense that with Dan I I
think he he also can play completely on
par with Magus and myself but but the
problem is is that he uh is that I feel
like in the critical moments he starts
worrying he starts respecting us too
much he expects us to just blow him away
and I think um yeah I i' say all R and
Daniel are probably the two two players
who I mean if if they could sort some of
those mental Kinks out they're I mean
they very easily could win against both
of us I I I think I think it's selling
it's really selling selling them short
to act as though they had no
chance yeah one player missing is nihal
saen what do you think about him if he
if he joins the field how does he stack
up yeah I mean NE actually I forgot
about neall he is the one player who I
believe was invited in Decline and
everybody's wondering why uh why he
didn't play I mean obviously I I have no
idea why he chose not to I I think that
you know it's been a while since I
played him in that SEC match but he
always performs very well I know that
when I think about players that I've
played online um he is the other player
who's very very pesky very annoying
somehow he keeps finding resources and
keeps the games going uh definitely
someone to watch um I I would say
actually nehal more so than any other
player near the top in in in recent
times he's very very reminiscent of
myself um very very reminiscent very
good at Blitz very good at bullet plays
online all the time much like I used to
when I was in like the mid 2600s and um
I mean I I think at some point he's he's
going to be able to turn on classical
chess but I think he's another player
that has great chances in all the online
formats if he's able to uh if if he's
able to to play I don't know why he
couldn't play but he he is he is the one
player who's kind of we we don't know
where he's at but he he could get up
there yeah we of course would love to
see nihal play in future additions and
he's always invited so he just needs to
accept uh but we have accepted a few
questions from the chat so uh the first
featured chat question I want to ask you
is from fuis jeno who says Hikaru how
did you regain yourself after having a
strong lead and Magnus being able to tie
up the
match well I mean I think the main thing
is that I just like I was in this Zone
where I wasn't even thinking about
anything kind of I mean I mean there
there was one moment that that it
bothered me um which was basically uh
when I lost that Bishop the Bishops of
opposite color ending where I tried to
go King C3 or no I tried to go to F2 and
win the G2 H3 pawns um that was the one
moment where I did look at the clock
around the time where I could have made
an easy repetition and um and I didn't
that's where I felt like I I thought for
a brief second there I had the match won
that was the one moment when I when I
let the situation kind of get in my head
a little bit but other after that um it
was it was more just like start the next
team just pound out or pound or Blitz
out what whatever adjective you want to
use um to get those moves on the board
as quickly as possible and then once
you're in the game and the time taking
down you don't have time to to think
about anything else and I think that was
the most important thing is that like
this start of the openings I was able to
Blitz out like 10 or 15 moves and I I
had no issues doing that um so it was
more that because it was bullet and I I
could make all those moves so quickly I
never really had such thoughts about um
about or the verb whatever same thing um
but but yeah you guys get the
point no it's great honestly this is
we've got more featured chat here but
it's great interview so I want to keep
stealing questions on my own I'm gonna
try to combine one so this is a question
from Johnny Baker 27 which he asked what
changed for you from the past when you
used to have a tough time against Magnus
and now you beat him and I'm going to
kind of build on that again with um the
psychological Edge that that again as
you said maybe used to exist or does
exist for Magnus in a lot of ways wasn't
there even though you watched Magnus
play really well today right he returned
to Norway he was on a roll he beat da
and Al Resa was there a part of you that
was kind of looking at Magnus and
worried about his form and and why do
you does he not have the same
psychological Edge over you anymore if
he used to well I mean there there are a
few reasons I I have no Ambitions in In
classical chess anymore I have no
Ambitions period in chess I'm a streamer
first um so that that's the most obvious
point A lot of people are going to make
more jokes and memes about it but at the
end of the day like if I think about it
from like Ali re's perspective u i mean
obviously I don't know for sure that
this is his perspective but you know
back when I was playing chess all the
time playing top tournaments there's
really only one goal you have in mind
and that is try to get into the canace
tournament if you can get there then you
know the chips will fall where they may
that's obviously very much a coin flip
or a roulette table when you're playing
in such an event cuz any Anything Can
Happen frankly but it's like get to that
tournament maybe get to a world
championship so that's really the only
thing you can think about and the
hardest part is that with Magnus always
there playing such insane chess you're
always worried about him then you see
him play all these games like you see
what he did against all res today
against Daniel the way he stormed back
against me and you it's just it's very
easy to just just sort of stop thinking
of him as a human it really is like you
you some some of these things that he
does on the board you just sometimes you
don't understand it I mean there are
many examples from my own games against
him that I could that I could use and I
I think the fact that I don't have such
thoughts anymore I don't really worry
about about trying to become world
champion or trying to get to number one
I mean these these things are just like
gravy on on top of the match potatoes as
we like to say uh here in the South um
so I I think for me it's just like I
just play I have fun and and also I have
to add separately though I think for
Magnus one of the perhaps M I don't want
to say mistakes but I think he's watched
he watched a lot of my streams during
the hard of the pandemic and I think
when you watch my streams it also
sometimes makes me seem better at chess
than I actually am too because I'm
explaining all these things all these
deep Concepts and I think that also
might play some role as well so I don't
know if I completely answered your
question but uh I mean I think it's just
I I don't care I just play have fun
whatever happens happens it nothing
changes in my world um you know I could
become world champion I'll still be a
streamer first nothing's going to change
so no no pressure no worries no stress
in life and I'm sure there's some
psychological some psychology
inspiration thing that video that
someone's done on this exact thing but
um it is what it is
wow well I mean you know it's always
good to hear you tell it like it is and
you say you don't feel the pressure but
it does sometimes feel like you know
you're still just improving almost and I
guess a question from the chat that's
related to this from Sahar Malik is what
is your best advice to get better at
bullet chest because Magnus did seem to
be an improved version of himself in
that final match and you Rose to the
occasion I mean bullet is so hard I mean
honestly I feel like bullet I I would
say for anybody who's not like 2600 Plus
plus just play it for fun don't think
about improving just just play it
because you want to play it that that's
really all that I think I can say I mean
I I would say if you're above that I I
would use like knall as an example of
somebody where he's plays all the time
online I think if you're if you're
trying to improve at bullet you should
play as much you can online if you have
the time um but again most of us don't
have that don't have the time to play
bull like 10 12 hours every day but I
was lucky that um that that you know
back when I was younger I did use to
play like I I had these great matches
and again like I can only just now now
I'm one of the old guys I'm not one of
the young guys anymore I remember you
know when I was like 12 13 14 on the
internet chest Club I play this Marathon
like five six hour matches with guys
like Hawkeye that German GM roll and
schalton like I mean I I was fortunate
to have that opportunity so I think you
just have to play as much as you humanly
can uh if if you have the opportunity
and you know also it was funny because
my openings against Oli Resa and Magnus
today were very much in the spirit of my
childhood openings the openings that I
learned from my stepfather but then also
that I played online all the time in
many of those bullet games it's was
always E4 Knight C3 and then like like
Grand Prix attack play like the the
Austrian attack against Hawkeye I mean
all all those all those great great
openings so um I think if you have the
time just play as much as you
can today was a throwback we mentioned
curtains earlier we mentioned the year
of the rabbit we mentioned Hawkeye this
is how you remind us of who we really
are that's a Nickelback reference hearu
Nickelback what's the best what about
Nickelback best song best Nickelback
song I don't listen to Nickelback come
on no actually you know did want to say
one thing uh I don't know which song was
on my playlist but there's there's one
great song during this match which
really got me grooving there was this
like this Indian song I I don't even
know I'm sure people in chat will know
what it is but there there was this
Indian song which I started singing to
which was like the best thing ever it
was cha chai I think it was like that
that was like the greatest thing ever
that really that really helped me just
get get get grooving um because I think
at that time I was ahead but that that
really got me into it so um the I mean
the Indian songs are great and no wonder
uh no wonder all these Indian players
are so good they should be so inspired
by by their by their
music all would for the win
man hey Carl we never want this event to
end we don't really want this interview
to end but we will let you keep grooving
on your stream congratulations once more
this was such a fantastic performance by
you thank you so much you guys have a
great one awesome can't wait for next
year see you man seriously I already
can't wait for next year's event I
literally can't wait for the next year's
B Championship nobody can wait can we
just instead of having a next year's can
we have like a next month's we just do
it next week
wait wait doesn't bull brawl happen
tomorrow where all the best players
including aaru da Jose Martinez Magnus
Tang Etc don't they just go and play
that that's uh that's a great call up
yeah bullet brawl tomorrow on Saturdays
and every Saturday forever more it's the
uh Saturday title Tuesday for those who
didn't know what happens best players in
the world playing bullet tomorrow if you
want more action but wow great interview
there and um we got another great
interview around the corner
here
yeah we're about to get Magnus Carlson
in for an interview you know even in
loss he still comes on so Magnus if you
can hear us thanks so much for joining
and sorry I didn't go your
way yeah can you hear me as well yeah we
got
you okay
good Magnus like Robert said thanks for
joining us even though it didn't go your
way let let me just ask the question
right after the B where do you if you
had to play this match over again is
there anything you would have done
differently where did you feel the
slightly went to
hikaro it's hard to say um I felt that
at the
start you know the first couple of games
uh he was out playing me uh completely
and then it was still pretty close and
then there was a stretch where he he was
building up a lead and I was
like so the the thing is
that I've
played uh I played some Bullets Over
over the years uh not that
much um specifically on on on cheson but
I I've played like over the years and
but the thing is I never played Hikaru
and I've seen senaru Crush everybody
else
uh and even in this tournament but I
always kind
of I always kind of thought that I
matched up decently with
um with him and that's
um s sort of my main strength I think
which is also his main strength is that
we're simply better at CH than the
others and so we can make good moves
more quickly so they need to to spend
time but then yeah at some point like he
was playing he was playing a lot faster
than I was and he was playing much
better seeing all kinds of tactics and
that was a
massive reality check for me I was uh at
that point I was thinking oh okay so
he's just not much better than I am um I
was like yeah fair enough uh this guy is
just a beast I
think um I think he was feeling the flow
at that point uh and U I think it was
the same as with Alesa like I was losing
a bunch of games in a row and just like
to get that one f one draw one win to
stop the bleeding think he became a bit
more um
defensive at a certain point and then I
actually had chances which I didn't
really think I I would at some point but
I yeah what I just want to say is I'm
I'm extremely I'm extremely impressed uh
I I mean I always knew that he was that
he was
that he was good um I always thought
that he was somewhat better than I was
at bullet but that he was like this much
better I didn't didn't realize and yeah
it's uh it's insanely
impressive Magnus that's extremely high
Praise of coming from you of all people
but the match was tied at 15 and then he
won the last two so it was a level match
and I guess on that note like how did
you improve your play over time back
home do you think that made a big
difference or what was it about today
where you elevated your
game yeah I was back home like that just
meant that I saw the I have a better
setup and I'm going to be I'm I mean I'm
still not fast in scrambles but I would
be like a little bit faster like I could
actually make they made up be good moves
but I'm actually like able to make quick
pre moves which just wasn't the last the
last few days and I I
think
um I mean I I said I said before the
tournament that I thought um that that I
thought Alesa and sharu were much better
than the others
um uh well except except for me I
thought I could compete with them and I
still sort of think that uh I still
think that Alesa is like a little bit
better than
than I am but yeah hiar
is very strong and yeah I I could
have uh I could have won the match for
for sure but
um yeah I wouldn't have felt like I
beat like that it would be just natural
I I mean at no point in the match did I
really
feel uh feel Superior at all
wow it's it's High Praise And Magnus how
much I know kind of a weird question but
how much does that does that motivate
you right and no way would we compare
online Bullet to the many titles You've
Won in your career World Championships
rapid and Blitz but how motivated do you
get when you play a format where you're
like huh like this guy's better than me
at this right does that motivate you
already even looking
ahead yeah a little bit like I'm just
really happy that I managed to get to to
the final and I didn't make a complete
fool of myself like if uh I mean if I'd
been blown out in the final that would
have been been fine just getting there
was was good but overall this is a very
good result for me I think you know
um if I if I was completely rested you
know maybe I'd have um I'd have a chance
to to up upset him
like I'm yeah like I I think he's
certainly better but maybe at at uh at
my
best um I'm I'm like good enough that
it's it's not a shock if I if I if I win
and I mean I can try to to improve a
little bit I I don't suspect that I'll
be practicing a lot um to be honest like
most of the time I just find playing
bullets
pretty pretty stressful but um but we'll
see uh I got to say
also before the match against T car as I
said like I was extremely happy to get
there but I felt like I'd already sort
of expended so much not so much energy
uh but more like nervous energy in the
in the match against Alara fortunately I
like the game the match against nitu was
pretty comfortable but I felt I felt a
bit drained after after the match with L
out but I'm happy uh it was it was a
good match uh and um I think overall you
know I'm pretty pretty proud actually of
my performance
here you should be proud of it for sure
Magnus on that note of you felt like you
expend a lot of energy we were Danny and
I were talking as the match was
beginning at zaru did you feel like you
would be with the advantage because you
were in the flow you've been playing
bullet for a few hours or that the rest
was more important so do you think that
it would have made a difference if you
had more time separated between your
match against ala and your match against
aaru uh I think um rest is more
important also because there is always
some s sense of
uh sense of flow
um but uh I mean in terms of um in terms
of rest I don't think it's about you
know th those hours necessarily it's
probably more that I should have uh
spent my time this week a bit
differently if I wanted to if I wanted
to optimize my results but um that's
um yeah that's fine I don't I don't yeah
I don't think you know the resting time
made made a massive difference you know
it's always say I I think it's a slight
Advantage but um not a big
deal more rest better bullet right who
would have known I only have one more
question Magnus I I texted you between
the da match and the other match about
holding alt when you promote did you
know that when he did that stalemate
trick if you hold alt and you take you
can get you can get a knight you know
that yeah I I I know it just didn't
occur to me that I could under promote
okay just yeah I mean at that point like
I was I already like had my guard down
uh I yeah yeah of course actually I
tried the same thing yesterday um in
that I I think we started this last game
with like eight seconds left or
something and I tried to start the last
game against uh Andrew as well just you
know so that we can get one more game of
practice but um yeah no I I I I I knew
it I I don't know if I've ever done it
actually so like if you're playing me in
bullet like yeah um and uh I have to
promote to a knight I I'll probably lose
some time
ro oh well you know it's something to
for someone to prepare against you and
we did ask the chat for some questions
and Galaxy milk 100 first of all great
username I wanted to know how did you
prepare for your match against aaro did
you do anything before your other
matches today or in the break or
anything like
that um no I mean I had I had an energy
drink and I tried to I poured some water
into my face and I
I tried to
um yeah I didn't I didn't know uh didn't
know what to do
like H yeah he's he's so
good also as as I said earlier like my
main advantage is that I can play faster
and like if I don't have that it's
really it's really it's really
tough I got one more question as well
from feature chat and I think you kind
of already answered this Magnus but we
want the fans to get their questions in
from Nill
2501 want Magnus can you please explain
the mouse Arc from the last couple days
maybe that was part of being home that
your actual physical setup was
different yeah that's the thing though
like I'm a little bit a little bit
faster from or probably a lot faster um
even though I'm still still slow um so
so yeah I also like I like the screen
the bigger screen better I feel like I
see the board
geometrical things in a better way even
though you know I
still blunder um every second move but
so does
everybody everyone makes mistakes yeah
it's it's true and thanks so much for
your thoughts mags we'll let you go but
I do want to wish you the best of luck
in the upcoming World Cup since I know
that event is starting soon but thanks
so much for joining us and I know second
place isn't first but congrats on really
an awesome
performance yeah thank you I'm I'm
really happy
thanks man see you
Magnus that was great great interview
there from the world number one former
world champion I don't even know how to
say that anymore it's awkward um but uh
he does take second place Robert and
hiar Nakamura is the man on top of them
all at the end of the day oh he is he
was the defending Champion he's the
champion once more and Magnus Carlson
slots there in second place and his
words said everything you needed to he
Hikaru is just so darn good I mean what
does anybody on this planet have to do
to overtake Hikaru and bullet that's a
question that remains unanswered but I'm
just happy to hear that Magnus is happy
not just as a person but that fact that
he could lose a match and still just
like wow that opponent is scary good and
he impressed me it shows what a
sportsman he is and I and I um I know
how he feels about playing in formats
where he doesn't consider himself the
favorite he loves it he he thrives and
and and and wants those opportunities um
and uh you know obviously he didn't get
this one today I think a momentum
turning into exhaustion thing right as
he said maybe he didn't spend his week
um in a way that allowed for the most
energy even here on a Friday um but but
despite how complimentary he was Robert
as you said it was a very close match
came down to overtime although I do also
agree with him and I think you would too
that if we had to think back about games
that got away from someone there were
more games that got away from Hikaru
that he probably should have won so the
truth is Hikaru is just so bleeping good
at bullet right and Magnus felt that
today despite how close it was and
complimentary he was there's a reason
Nakamura is the guy at the end of the
day yeah no Hikaru just stands at top
the mountain as the bullet Champion he
earned it as you just said and as Magnus
admitted that Hikaru had some opportuni
slip out of his fingertips and it maybe
could have been a different match but
still it was into overtime it was a
two-point win for hikara nakor Magnus
Carlson and I guess I have one final
question for you well I have two first I
just thought about this you didn't ask
Magnus about Nickelback so go text him
right now and ask him for his favorite
song so we can tell everybody before the
show ends but you know more relevant
what are who impressed you most about
this event and what do you look forward
to for next
year wow um honestly I'm gonna I'm GNA
say this like I mean this totally
genuinely
I was impressed by The Format as a fan I
will be honest I've never watched this
much of the bullet chest championship
before because in past years Robert I
commentated with you or there were there
was a year where I didn't but I I'll be
honest I didn't get to watch that much I
was impressed by how enjoyable this was
because I think sometimes bullet you
know presents in a way that's almost too
fast right you don't get those
instructive moments that you get in even
just a little bit slower chest three
minute or five minute but this was so
much fun it was so much fun to watch the
matches were so hype and was so close so
I just I'm going to say like the format
was the most impressive it was an
amazing show to watch you were
incredible um I really mean that and I
but then I also will say at the end of
the day that hikaro Nakamura just
continues to deliver it's insane it's
insane and even though he says uh what
he does about about being a streamer the
truth is he is probably playing the best
chess of his career and I think it
probably is true that regardless of
whether you got to that phrase as a meme
or not the fact that he literally
doesn't care has somehow brought out the
best of his talent
and it's crazy to watch and so much fun
to think that we will have future
matches where these two guys are playing
um for probably for years to come and I
don't remember where I first heard it
but it's good to be nervous because you
care but not because you're scared
Hikaru Nakamura if he ever was scared he
is scared no more of Magnus Carlson
there's a ton of mutual respect there
and Hikaru earns this title ahead of
Magnus just like he did at the 20122
speed Chess Championship and this
concludes the event that is the bullet
Chess Championship but we have more
great events for you it may not be
played at a lightning Pace it may not
involve hikara or Magnus but we have POG
Champs 5 starting at the end of the
month 16 of the world's biggest creators
will go head-to-head in the greatest
event in amateur chess brought to you by
chess.com and pogchamps Legend lwig
watch your favorite creators like cutie
Cinderella SE dog VA xqc Tyler one I did
a thing and the others fight for their
share of a $100,000 prize fund and a
ticket to the live finals where Danny
wrench will be in Los Angeles use the
command POG in chat for all the details
Danny I'm super thought you were G to
say also it may not even have good chess
sorry I thought you were going to say it
may not even have good chess but it's
great and then we already teased some of
the players I didn't know we were going
to do that but yeah Tyler one is playing
this year there's some other really big
names that are joining we're going to
tease later so sorry I stole your
thunder as you send us send us out here
but go ahead man you you could never
steal my thunder unless it's Tropic
Thunder but we should probably not talk
about that movie on air but no I was
going to
say it's always a true pleasure to be
joined by you I mean over the years
we've commentated so many events and so
many different venues online different
time controls different formats uh but
it's always an absolute pleasure
especially for as you said this format
win by two double elimination bullet
chess Hikaru Magnus ala da we've seen it
all and we've had a
blast I don't even know that I got much
else to say you're the the man much love
you crushed it this week this was so
much fun fans Circle your calendar for
whenever we announce the bullet chip
Championship next year cuz it's going to
be just as lit and uh thank you for
having me Robert oh it's always a
pleasure and thanks to everybody who's
tuned in each and every day we
appreciate every one of you thanks for
the thoughtful questions thanks for
supporting all the players and just
thanks for loving chess so until next
time this has been Robert Hess and Danny
wrench and we appreciate you all have a
good
one only 13 minutes remain right now oh
we have a blunder that going to get it
with the fist pump Magnus is almost in
the territory where he can just start
letting the clock hit it's stalemate if
you take the Rook that's what's going on
here and Magnus I am calling the
momentum out Magnus has already won a
match today he's looking fresh feeling
fresh in his home environment and perua
is going to win his sixth game in a row
bullet is a is a game of momentum more
than anything else and peruja is on fire
right now Magnus Carlson has turned this
thing around and and now he's bobbing
his head to music again peruja needs to
find it wo he resigned seconds early and
peruja leans back and Magnus is
celebrating Magnus moves on to the Grand
Final and uh and Magnus is going to
level things up in this game unless
something wild happens he also has a
huge Edge on the clock unreal play thus
far from mararo he's fast he's playing
very accurately and he's getting to the
end games where he can play for two
results as we say in classical chess
Magnus he wins a quick game there it's
only a two point spread 10 seconds here
comes the
a before it's a TI match it's a tied
match and they get one more game I think
God and he pre moved King h8 and he's
just losing the game but look at Magus
just get those Queens off the board and
then oh he didn't even have to hiar
resigned Hikaru going in wait there was
a blunder we'd be six yeah this is
promoting he allowed the queen in the P
you see it on mag's face he knows that
does is how Nakamura defended his bullet
just championship
title
[Music]